Four,
three,
two,
one.
Hello Barry.
Hi.
And that we're live.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
It's a very fortuitous your timing comes
right in the middle of this big hubbub
about this native American elder in this
young boy with one of those stupid
fucking red hats on that.
Would you have ever imagined that a
slogan make America great again?
Would be so divisive as somehow or
another like that.
That would be like make America great
again.
It sounds like they just want to make
things great.
Like all positive.
No red hat with white letters.
Has there ever been a time like that
where an object like a red hat with
white letters was so repulsive to half
the country?
Yes.
Well,
I mean some people see it as the
equivalent of a white hood.
Wow.
I don't know about that.
I think,
I believe.
Do they do what they believe that
wearing it,
wearing it that a 16 year old wearing
that hat sort of carries intense moral
weight that surely we know that a 16
year old is not aware of all the
implications of wearing that hat.
Yeah,
but the problem with that is Kanye wears
it,
right?
Fair enough.
It doesn't really work.
I agree.
I'm just saying there are people who
really make that argument.
I get it.
I know the people who are paid for their
opinions.
Well,
yeah.
there's also people that are calling for
this child's name and address or calling
to docs him and publicly expose him.
This is a child.
He's 16.
Is that what he is?
He's 16 years old and it was one of the
things that was just so amazing about
the whole brouhaha around.
I mean it was even a way like this
perfect encapsulation of our outrage
culture.
Right,
because people saw a tiny clip of this
video and it was like a Rorschach test
you saw in it this morality play of what
would it look to be,
was a group of mostly white kids from
Coventry Catholic school.
I think it's in Kentucky and it looked
like at first glance that they were
smirking and smug and had these sort of
shifting and grins on their faces and
that they were surrounding this older
native American man and I have to tell
you,
I had a visceral reaction to it.
The second I saw it,
like so many other people.
I was like,
this is,
you know,
where we are in our broken culture and
they're bullying this guy and here's the
rise of the.
I had all of those reactions.
The challenge of what it means to be a
journalist is to not see people as
signifiers or as stand ins just based on
their identity.
And that's what like 94,
95 percent of the press corps did.
They sort of leapt to the leap to assume
that,
you know,
are visceral reaction was accurate when
in fact when you actually looked at like
the two hour video of the whole
interaction,
which also included this group of black
Israel lights or Hebrew Israelites,
they called.
It was not that at all.
The native American man had walked up to
this group,
the four other guys had been heckling
the group beforehand,
calling them crackers,
calling them Satan,
calling the one black kid in the group,
things that can't even be said.
So it was just far more complicated.
Um,
and what,
what was really,
really disheartening is that the initial
outrage was enough for the mainstream
press to report on it.
Like twitter has kind of become almost
an assigning editor for places like the
New York Times and the Washington Post
and the Wall Street Journal.
And then when the actual truth of the
thing comes out,
when we move past the outrage cycle,
they have to sort of write the followup
story to the fake outrage to begin with.
I'm defending the fake outrage instead
of backing up and saying we made a
mistake.
Right.
Well,
some people said that they made a
mistake.
That's wonderful.
That's a good sign.
Yes,
it really is.
One of the things that was so horrifying
was that people that are supposed to be
adults,
you know,
people with blue check marks on twitter
were saying things like,
this is the face of white patriarchy.
The 16 year old kid
raise the US on set.
Have you ever seen him more punchable
face?
Kathy Griffin was saying,
I need names.
Shame him.
Docs him.
How do these people not understand the
implications of that?
So what happened over the weekend was
that the,
you know,
sleuthy detectives on twitter found a
kid who they thought was the kid in the
video,
wasn't actually the kid.
So there's the actual kid who was docs.
The family was harassed.
Everything that we now know happens in
these outreach cycles.
But then there was another kid who looks
suspiciously like him who was not him at
all,
whose family.
There was an amazing and heartbreaking
twitter thread about it,
whose family was in the middle of a
family wedding and they spend their
whole weekend fighting off these mobs
who were trying to destroy them.
And it wasn't even the kid in the video.
I mean,
that is really horrifying to me that
that's where we are and the fact that
adults who should know better or
fomenting this and don't see how thin
like the v s sounds heavy,
but like the veneer of civilization is
like they're taking a pickax to it.
It's just.
I just found the whole thing to be
terrifying.
I don't know how you felt
exactly the same way and I think it's a
very unique moment because it's so
public and it's so.
It's so prevalent in whether it's
twitter or facebook,
it's everywhere and it sort of embodies
everything that's wrong with a lack of
nuance and with people taking one side
versus the other and sticking with it
with not confronting their own personal
biases with looking at these things
through the eyes of this is the enemy.
I'm on the good side.
They're on the bad side.
Let's get them.
And also this,
this distorted idea of what it takes to
what it takes to be violent.
Like this idea of this is a punchable
person like calling for violence.
You,
you're,
you're hearing a lot of this.
Like,
this is one of the things that troubles
me so much about the left.
My family,
my parents were hippies.
You know,
I grew up when I was a little kid.
We lived from age of seven to 11 and San
Francisco during the Vietnam War.
While the Vietnam War was ending,
I was living in the middle of the hippie
world.
I always felt that people on the left,
we're like these well read kind,
compassionate people,
but somewhere along the line,
within the last few years,
people on the left are calling for
violence.
This is very.
This is very confusing to me,
and it's.
It's this frivolous social media call
for violence.
It's not an in person,
be their boots on the ground call for
it.
It's a very strange call for Violence
Punch Nazis.
I'm hearing this all the time because
it's right,
because it's.
Sorry,
go ahead.
What I'm going to say is what does a
Nazi okay?
If you mean punch actual Nazis that are
putting Jews in the concentration camps.
I'm with you,
but when you call a guy with a Maga hat
on,
he wears one of those red hats and he's
just an asshole.
He's a Nazi.
Now,
some guy who maybe is not that educated
want to be a contrarian,
sees all these liberals that are
complaining all the time so it puts this
red hat on and now he's a white
supremacist and a Nazi and you want to
punch him like,
okay,
that's with a lot of people in very high
positions of power in this country,
at least in the culture actually believe
and they don't understand the
implications of hollowing out words like
that.
I know this personally,
right?
Because I'm called alt right.
I'm called an apologist for rape
culture.
I've been called everything.
I'm a centrist.
Okay.
I'm.
I'm a Jewish center left on most things.
Person who lives on the upper west side
of Manhattan and you know it's super
socially liberal,
liberal on pretty much any issue you
want to choose.
If I'm alt right,
what?
What words do we have left for people
that actually are that?
Exactly what words do we have left for
people who actually are part of a sort
of racist blood and soil nativism that's
rising in this country and around the
world that should terrify people that
are using that language in the sloppiest
of ways.
I really don't think they're seeing the
implications of it.
I also think that when,
when you're just,
you know,
your keyboard warrior and you're just
tossing this stuff out,
so much of it is about signaling to your
tribe that you know,
that this thing is bad and I really
don't think people are understanding the
implications of this and I don't think
it's a stretch to imagine something like
this happening a week,
two weeks,
a month,
two months from now and someone actually
getting killed.
Right?
Like Charlottesville mean.
Very,
very similar to what happened there.
This,
this,
this kind of.
I mean when that guy drove over those
protesters,
the ramping up of the dialogue on both
sides,
the rhetoric,
the violent talk,
it's so disturbing and so unnecessary.
Especially when it's disingenuous.
Like calling someone like you alright or
me cry.
I get called alt right adjacent.
That's what I hear,
that one all the time.
I'd go left on everything basically
except guns.
There's a few things that I'm like
repeal the second amendment.
Yeah.
But I,
I do think that there should be some
restrictions for gun use.
Just like I think there should be
restrictions for car use.
I actually think there should be testing
for guns and you should have to go look.
You have to go through a fucking.
You have to take driver's Ed to get a
car license.
How come you don't have to do any,
you know,
you don't have to do anything to get a
gun like you once.
If you're not a criminal,
you just get a gun.
Like you don't have to know how to take
care of it and clean it and sit safely.
Handle it.
You don't have to know the ethics of
use.
You don't have to know anything.
No.
It's insane.
I mean,
and I just spent six weeks in Australia
where they had basically one major
massacre 20 years ago and then I forget
who it was.
We could look it up,
but you know,
prime minister conservative got rid of
guns.
Yes.
Everyone in the country,
they think we're insane and psychotic
the way that we live where we're
definitely weird.
The thing also,
one other thing that,
that
jumped out to me about the Catholic
school boy incident,
it kind of signifies something broader
that's happening,
which is the eraser of the individual,
which is just,
I think a horrifying problem in our
culture.
Like what actually happened was one our
incident on a random afternoon in
January between a group of individuals.
Right.
But instead in our mind,
why was everyone there?
The boys were there for the march for
life.
Um,
I don't know why the Hebrew Israelites
were there,
but it's DC,
like they're crazy protesters all the
time.
You know,
at the Lincoln memorial and outside of
the White House were there for a school
event?
Is that what we're there for the march
for life as part of their school and
they had like,
been had free time I think.
And then we're converging at the Lincoln
Memorial.
They didn't have a chaperone.
There's no,
no.
I think the teachers,
there was a teacher there and they had
asked the teacher at one point in order
to drown out the heckling of the Hebrew
Israelites,
I hope I'm getting the name of that
group right.
Could we do a school cheer to kind of
ignore them?
And they did that and I think they did
that with permission from the teachers
at one point early on it was rumored
that they were chanting build the wall,
but no one has surfaced any evidence of
that whatsoever.
Well,
that's what I heard from the native
American elder when he was talking about
innovation in the video.
He said they were chanting out build
and maybe they were.
I just haven't seen anything and I've
watched every video.
It's totally possible there also 16.
Right.
Make your friends
laugh and they're assholes and they're
just being silly and stupid.
Right.
And I have to say,
as someone who was a total nerd in high
school,
I saw the face of the main kid in that
still photograph and that video and like
the 14 and 15 year old girl in me with
like enraged,
really like I was like I see the face of
so many kids who said the nastiest
things to me and who through friends of
mine into garbage cans,
like the,
like disgusting bullying.
Was it because the thing is you have to
get to the next step if you're a jerk.
No,
we was.
It was.
Yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
If he's just standing there,
it's the hat face.
Maybe even still if it's a group,
but he put the.
My thing is like your initial reaction
to something is not the truth.
It's your emotional reaction.
And anyone who calls themselves a
journalist like your job is to figure
out the facts of the case.
Not to make this into a kind of
identitarian morality play.
And the fact that so many people in so
many publications did just that.
And in fact,
when the real facts surfaced,
just sort of dug their heels in and were
basically like,
well,
he's a stand in for the white
patriarchy.
What?
That's crazy.
Like there was an actual buzzfeed writer
that said it.
It's the look of white patriarchy,
his face.
You're really going to put that on a 16
year old,
would we?
Like,
it's just nuts to me.
Well,
it's cruel.
It's a denial of the individual.
It's very cruel.
When you're 16 years old,
you're basically a baby.
You don't know what the fuck you're
doing.
You're incredibly susceptible to the
influence of your peers.
You're around a bunch of other boys.
You're not around girls cause you don't
go to school with girls because he goes
some wacky religious school,
right?
That this is,
you know,
you want to really be a social justice
warrior.
You really want to save the world.
How about you do something about the
Catholic Church?
Everyone wants to go after our Kelly,
which is great.
But how about the Catholic Church?
How about the number one kid fucking
organization of all times?
That's what it is.
And I,
I was raised Catholic,
I know what it is.
Did anything happen?
And nothing happened to me.
I got lucky,
but I know people.
I know a bunch of people.
I know a bunch of people with stories
and this is all over the world.
Oh yeah,
but these kids come from that Colt.
Imagine if that was not the Catholic
church.
If it was insead,
scientology,
we will be going,
oh,
these kids are a part of a cult.
They went there.
They were part of this weird cult that
suppresses sexuality amongst its priests
and encourages the placement of these
pedophile priests in new places in order
to get away from whatever crime they've
committed in the area where they were
initially established.
This is what the Catholic church is,
right?
But then they travel all over the place,
but it also is good people.
This is the.
This is where the nuance comes into
play.
It's good people.
There's a bunch of people that are
Catholics because they want a better
with God or the universe or love or
whatever.
They feel like it's a good moral
framework for their children.
They take them there,
they believe in the 10 commandments,
they believe in this moral structure for
society that's laid down by what they
believe is God.
There's great people that are involved
in the Catholic church,
but it's also the number one kid fucking
organization the world.
It's those two things,
right?
So these kids are a part of something
that's way worse than smirking at a
native American with a drum.
And in my opinion,
being A.
I remember when I was 16,
I was a fool.
I was a dumb person,
you know,
I was bullied,
I was little,
small and I learned martial arts when I
was 15.
I mean,
I'm sure it was a dick to some people
just because I can get away with it.
I don't,
I don't really remember it,
but I'm definitely girls differently.
People are dicks.
You're trying it out,
you know,
you don't even know how to talk yet.
You basically just learning words and
this kid with this guy beating the drum
inches from his face.
He handled it,
I believe way better than I was.
I don't think I would have.
I don't see.
I mean,
I don't think so.
No,
No one knows.
16 pop punk.
When I was 16 to also I was competing.
I was doing a lot of martial arts
events,
so maybe I would've kept it together
better than I'm.
I'm thinking I would have,
but I definitely was a fucking idiot and
I was 16.
You know,
you just don't.
And who knows what's going on that day,
who knows?
Like if you have the anxiety about the
future of your girlfriend broke up with
you or you failed the test or what else
that is like bouncing around inside your
head.
Overwhelming your ability to form
reasonable thoughts
by the way that everyone's initial.
Not everyone's every liberal.
I know.
Okay.
Everyone on the center and center left
and even the center reits reaction to it
was accurate that he was a little
asshole and he's a racist,
homophobic,
transphobic hates immigrants in every
single thing.
Does that deserve to be news that a 16
year old kid with those views smirked at
a native American elder?
Especially considering what he actually
did?
No,
I don't think that's news.
Not only that,
I think it's strange that we're covering
it like it is and because of the
Internet,
the fact that we're my timeline on
twitter and on facebook and on
everything.
This was way bigger news than day,
whatever it is,
30,
31 of the government shutdown where
people are having to get on breadlines
to feed their families.
Then here's the thing,
is it like it's people what it's what
people want to talk about.
I think there's this idea that there's
things that are happening right now like
the government shutdown and then there's
things that are happening right now in
terms of our culture shifting and when
these things that come up in opposition
to what many people believe is a
beneficial shift to a more progressive,
more responsible culture.
When these little hiccups,
they get addressed and they get address
rapidly and I think it's because people
are aware that things are changing in
this almost like unprecedented way.
If you look back on pace.
I agree with that.
Yeah,
like nothing we've ever.
There's nothing that you could find in
the historical record for human beings
is ever been what we've experienced over
just the past 10 plus years of social
social networks and social media and the
ability to spread information very
quickly with a youtube video or a tweet
or whatever,
or I mean these,
these,
the way people are exchanging
information is,
is very different and because of that
culture is shifting at a hyperspace
speed.
It's just turbo charged for sure.
So I think when something comes up that
we think is like,
ah,
there's one get it.
Exactly.
But it's not logical.
It's like it's like road rage.
You know why you get road rage?
One of the reasons because you're going
fast.
Okay,
you're in a car and you're nervous.
You're,
you're heightened senses.
So anything that happens,
it gets magnified.
Like someone's,
you look motherfucker in my lane,
Hong Kong because you already jacked up
to eight because you're in a car going
60 miles an hour on twitter.
Does that.
Twitter's doing that 100 percent.
Social media is doing that.
Life is doing that.
So when something like this comes up,
this rapid pace of change,
which is almost an impossible to keep up
with,
right?
With the new cycle and this constant
wave of change and information.
So when something comes up,
people were road raging on this kid.
Totally.
That's why we just have to.
I mean there's,
there's lots of things to say,
but one thing has just continued to
insist on truth and facts.
Yes.
And not allowing people to be ins for a
group.
You're not a stand in for anyone.
You're yourself.
You answered for yourself.
And I just,
I find that trend on both sides really,
really scary.
It's because people are insecure and you
know,
I think for someone like Cathy who's
experienced,
Kathy Griffin,
who's experienced that public shaming,
that amazes me,
right?
Like she's been publicly shamed herself
in the most horrific way.
Has he basically had to live underground
and now she's saying shame him,
name him and docs.
It reinforces,
it reinforces people's idea that they
should be more,
more committed to their side,
more committed to their team.
The only way you're going to get any
support if you have been attacked and
isolated,
not alone,
is to get back deep,
deep into the team again.
Like how do you get back deep into the
team again?
You've got to be fucking rabid,
you know,
and that's part of it.
It's a,
it's a natural reaction that people have
to sort of signal to everyone else on
the team.
They're all in,
they're fully committed.
They don't even care about their fucking
career.
I'm an activist like that kind of shit
happens and it's,
it's people that want love.
That's what a lot of it is.
It's they.
They do recognize that there's something
wrong they'd,
they are reacting to a real thing.
Not denying that,
but I am saying that the reason,
the overwhelming reason,
the motivation for this kind of
overzealous reaction is often a
signaling thing.
So they want to let everybody know I'm
on the fucking team,
man.
I'm all in.
Let's go punch Nazis.
And the people that I've talked to,
people that have said that and in real
life,
and I'm like,
man,
you,
you can't punch any,
but you shouldn't punch anybody.
They're going to punch you back.
What do you don't punch first of all?
Who's your savior?
Punch for a real,
real,
real one,
you know,
in Poland or in Hungary right now,
right?
Right.
Know,
not at,
not a 16 year old kid who maybe has no
idea what that had signifies.
Well,
I mean,
and I mean there's a broader point which
is like the very same people,
like one of the sort of wisdoms of,
of criminal justice reform,
right,
is which I believe in,
is that we shouldn't try kids as adults
and we should forgive.
We should have greater generosity and
mercy and forgiveness for the crimes of
a child.
Even if they're,
they've committed them.
Those same people are the ones saying
him and shame him generally.
Politically.
Well,
you're seeing that now.
And this is again,
there's never been a doxing before.
There was no doxing.
Right?
How long has [inaudible] been around?
A decade.
Well,
thank you.
Since Game Gamergate is when it got
huge,
right?
Yeah.
Maybe let's go crazy and say the first
doxing was 20 years ago.
That's a blip,
right?
That's so recent.
So you know,
this is not a thing that people have
really had to balance out in their mind
when to do it and when not to do it,
they just do it.
I think people have no idea of what that
looks like.
Right?
And unless you've experienced it or
watch someone,
you know,
experience it,
it's like it's like an abstraction
because these people are abstractions.
They're two dimensional little puppets.
That's exactly what it is.
And this extreme lack of empathy.
The lack of empathy towards anyone who
doesn't share your position.
This is very strange.
It's um,
it's very,
it's piss poor thinking and it's
everywhere and in.
Everyone wants to feel like not being a
part of one of the tribes is that
extremely lonely position and you get
called all the bad names because people
want you to be a part of their tribe and
people don't want to be called that name
is.
And they want to feel like they're in an
ingroup huddle,
like emotionally.
I totally got that kind of sucks being
homeless.
Well,
it's just politically homeless.
It's just
when you got a president that's so
polarizing and you have an opposition to
him that's so there,
there,
there's so much momentum in opposing
him.
And I think this is a giant wedge in
between these two sides.
And then you have that hat and that hat.
If that kid wasn't wearing that hat a
guaranteed be like 20 percent less hate,
it would be.
It would be great.
People would still get mad at him
because he was staying like.
I've seen people say when a native elder
walks up to you and he's banging his
drums,
get the fuck out of the way.
I saw that.
Like,
come on,
you can't expect that you what?
You can't just beat your drum.
First of all,
he got right in the kids face like
inches from the kid's face.
Pretty amazing.
The restraint this kid had to just
smile.
And the idea that you're going to judge
this kid.
Millions and millions and millions of
people are going over this right now.
That kid woke up that morning,
he had no fucking idea.
He was a kid in a cult.
Okay?
He's in a Catholic school and he's going
to some weird thing,
some march for life where people trying
to kill babies.
We've got to stop them from killing
babies,
right?
And he goes there and there's this black
Israelites calling them the faggots and
there's all these people calling them
names and then all of a sudden this
guy's beating the drum in front of his
face and we're supposed to.
We're supposed to dock this kid now
because he smirked.
That's crazy.
An impossible lack of empathy.
It's impossible to defend like unless
you hate boys,
unless you hate all boys because boys
are dumb.
Like 16 year old boys are almost
universally dumb.
They all,
they all grow up to be men.
Some of those men will be your best
friend,
so when those men will be amazing,
some of those men would be so happy to
see.
When you see him,
you give him a big hug.
Okay,
that's me.
That's me.
I was a stupid fucking 16 year old and
I'm a man now and I try to be as nice as
I can to everybody.
I go way out of my way to be a kind
person that could be that kid to like
what you're doing is not good for
anybody.
It's not.
It's not good for society to take this
trend and run with it and this is,
well,
this is what people do now you know,
you dock 16 year olds turbo charges the
right,
like think people are not quite
understanding that dynamic.
If you're someone who you know is
frustrated with trump and is maybe
moving to the middle and you know,
imagine that person,
it's easy to imagine.
Then you see this and you're like,
I don't let those people being in charge
of me.
I don't want those people running the
government.
That's the visceral reaction.
I just,
I don't think they're understanding the
implications of what they're doing.
I don't think they understand that they
do.
Maybe they didn't know.
There's no mastermind behind this.
There's and there's no understanding.
I think they do understand their
implications that when you have a
spectrum right,
the far right and the far left,
they have a very similar reaction as
they drive a person to the other side,
the person that sees the far right and
sees repulsive racism and bigotry that,
you know,
build that wall.
Fuck these Mexicans,
fuck those little kids.
They should have known better.
They're all illegals.
That kind of person that pushes people
towards progressivism,
it pushes people towards much more
liberal,
even socialist ideology.
It's like fuck that gross snus.
And the same thing can be said for
someone like,
I'm going to send you something,
Jamie.
This is a real poster that Antifa is
sending.
They
were putting on,
um,
on wall,
on walls and fence posts and shit in the
Pacific northwest.
And it's actually kind of hilarious
because it's so stupid.
I'm gonna.
Send it to Jamie and Jamie's going to
put it up on the screen here,
but,
uh,
it,
it says,
whoops,
wrong one.
Jamie,
sorry.
Jamie Kilstein.
Here you go buddy.
I just sent it.
It says,
when you date a white,
it's not all right.
And it's like,
it's telling people to not date white
people.
Propagation of lights is propagation of
hatred,
oppression,
homophobia,
sexism,
transphobia,
racism,
enablism.
Now followers.
So are we supposed to sterilize white
people?
There it is.
We can see it up on the big screen.
So it's even closer because it's large.
But see,
this is the thing.
Racism is.
Racism is terrible,
right?
So how do you stop racism?
Racism is,
can only be perpetrated by white people.
Oh,
well the problem is white people.
We've got to stop white people.
Well now you're racist.
Like you're literally being racist to
stop.
Is this really?
Well,
there are people are finding it and
posting it online and someone sent it to
me.
Um,
I don't know if it's everywhere.
It's probably just one asshole.
Right?
But the person exists,
but that person exists and they think
they're a progressive.
Do you see the cold civil war that we're
in in this country?
No,
I hope not.
That's why I worried about this punch
style.
This go.
No one knows.
If we did,
we could make a lot of money in the
stock market.
This is,
this is why I'm concerned,
especially because I understand violence
a lot better than most people do.
You can't just say go punch people when
raise the Oslo and says,
have you seen a more punchable face that
is so fucking dangerous because you're
almost saying,
go punch this kid.
I saw someone else.
I accidentally favored something.
I didn't mean to favorite favorite it.
I did.
Someone pointed to me and I'm just lucky
that I looked at it because I normally
don't even read comments,
but somebody pointed out that I favored
a really preposterous tweet that said,
honest.
It said the reply from the school is
pathetic and impotent.
Name these kids.
Oh,
that's Kathy Griffin a.
here's the one that said it.
This guy said,
God damn it,
I can't find it.
He was basically saying,
no need to hear.
It is a face like that never changes.
This image will define his life.
No need,
no one need ever forgive him,
and this is the person with the blue
check mark by their name.
No one need ever forgive him.
A face like that defines his life.
That is virtual signaling in the most
toxic form,
so,
so dangerous to think like that.
The idea of it just.
I'm sorry.
Trying to.
No,
it's okay.
The idea that people cannot change to
irredeemable,
right is crazy.
Cancel culture.
I was talking about this with,
with Kanye.
Honestly.
You're talking about cancel cultures
here on the show.
We're talking about a person on the
phone.
Okay.
Just going to be on the show.
Cool.
Allegedly,
he's a little nervous to see him with a
Samurai sword posing and he would go
with the Elon musk on that poster.
It's been.
It was first posted over two years ago
and it's supposedly as a like a troll.
Oh yeah,
that makes sense.
But this is the world where it's hard.
Define what's a troll was.
What I was going to say that if I was
cynical,
I would say that if I was a person who
is like far right,
I wouldn't put that up.
Of course,
just to fuck with these people and sweet
people.
I mean it's basically like some CIA
psyops type shit.
You know what I mean?
This is this worth so through the
looking glass here.
They'll like that post that I just read
you.
That's a real post about this guy is
unredeemable.
No one knew.
Never forgive him.
That's just as bad in my opinion.
Is that poster saying,
don't date white people.
It's all crazy.
We pressing no,
no.
Here's the thing.
You have to like fight.
I have to fight this feeling of despair.
You have to like,
I find myself fighting it because the
basic like some like basic virtues,
right?
That used to be normal,
Like civility,
civility has now become,
for some people a code word for like
complicity with Nazi-ism.
Like if you're,
if you're civil and you believe in
civility and you believe in,
you know,
treating people decently and with giving
them the benefit of the doubt like that,
that word itself has become a code or a
signal in a negative way.
Empathy,
like human doubt.
Even saying it.
I don't know.
You know,
I,
I just,
these basic virtues seemed to have been
swept away and I don't know when they,
when they got lost.
Well,
a key ingredient for sure.
The thing that hardened the epoxy was
trump.
I think these trends,
these trends are going in that direction
anyway,
but he capitalized on that.
You know,
he's a very smart manipulator.
He knew how to capitalize on that.
I mean,
this chant of build that wall,
it's not an accident.
That's something that he concentrates on
and it's not just that it's there.
We're in a political battle right now
because if they get him to back down off
the wall,
then he looks like a loser when 20,
20 comes around,
he looks less powerful to all those
people.
There's that for sure,
but there's also this.
He's so egregious like everything.
He's so he sold that guy.
Well,
he's gotten rid of all the guardrail,
like he's broken the damn.
My question,
like thinking about how we're going to
get beyond this is how do we build it
back because he's broken something or he
signifying the fact that it was broken.
One or the other.
I think that he was both a symptom of
something that was broken that we didn't
recognize and now he's further catalyze
that,
broken it.
Well,
I think both sides have to recognize
that the other side has some points.
That's one thing,
and then I think we also have to treat
ourselves like all family.
We're all in a big team because that's
what we really are.
If we really are the United States of
American,
I mean what?
What is it?
What is a country?
I mean if anything,
we're supposed to be a team.
The idea that we're separated and were
two teams in this one team.
The real differences in terms of who
gets elected,
like how it's going to affect your life,
involve business,
involves some social policies,
involve some things,
but the way we interact with each other
on a day to day,
it doesn't involve that at all.
That has to be fixed first.
The way we think about each other on a
day to day basis.
They used to be a time where you could
have a conservative friend and you can
be a liberal and you could be a fucking
long haired Hippie guy and as long as
you're a good hardworking person who
didn't let their long go crazy,
your next door neighbor who was like a
goldwater Republican would talk to you
and you would go,
how's it going,
Mike?
What's going on with,
oh,
you know,
guys at the forest or try to put
together this case and this and that,
and you know,
a professor could live right next to a
cop and they would be friends and one
would be conservative and one would be
liberal and they would make fun of each
other a little bit and rib each other a
little bit and that would be the end of
it.
That would be it.
It wouldn't be this civil war that we're
experiencing right now,
right now,
just verbal and hopefully it stays that
way,
but it's.
It's,
it's confusing.
It's confusing because there's a lack of
a frustrating lack of empathy that when
I look at human beings and when I look
at people that aren't seeing what
everyone else was seeing or they're not
seeing things objective,
Lee and their rational and overly
emotional,
I always assume there's something else
to running from.
I always assume when I see someone
lashing out and insulting everyone
around them,
I always assume it's not the people
around that it's something internal.
There's some something,
maybe some existential angst.
They're fighting against some
realization of the futility of life.
Whatever the bucket is mean.
Finite organisms playing this game as if
it lasts forever and accumulating stuff
is if it's going somewhere with you like
it's going to get in that wooden canoe
and the God is going to take it with you
in the afterlife.
It's nonsense and somehow or another we
know this and we as especially as people
get older,
they seem to push it further and further
in the back of their mind and they get
more and more ideologically based.
They're less open minded.
They're less open to nuance.
It's very rare to see a 65 year old guy
switched parties that's calcified.
You become that guy,
you know?
Yeah.
That fucking asshole uncle that has a
couple of drinks in them and starts
talking about the gays,
you know,
and this and that and all the things
that are wrong with our culture,
the sodomites,
you know,
people start talking crazy.
Ever heard that at a Thanksgiving
dinner?
I haven't either.
But um,
I think there's a few things that can
help us.
One I think is just time realizing that
these stupid fucking blow ups over this
kid and the discussion that comes
afterwards,
hopefully some of this will settle down.
We're allowed to have disagreements.
We're allowed to have opinions about how
these kids should have behaved,
were allowed to have ideas in there,
in our minds about how,
how you would behave if you were that
kid,
but I don't think you're allowed to dock
some.
I don't think you're allowed to even say
that.
I don't think you're allowed to say that
you want to punch him.
I think that needs to become socially
unacceptable to do that.
Yeah.
You need,
you need to be checked for that because
that's,
you know when,
when someone says things like eyes him
who's,
who's punched him,
he punched you buddy.
Who's ever punched you?
Punched.
Feels like
he might.
Georgia probably punch them.
Jordan's more of a I'll punch you type
of a guy.
I don't think Sam would ever say you
would punch somebody.
I cannot.
I have to say I can not imagine
everything that's on that.
I will punch you.
Well,
you know the feeling of I'm going to
punch you,
but I can never imagine it's.
Yeah,
I mean,
unless you're protecting someone you
care about or your own self.
Although I did see this amazing video of
Buzz Aldrin to.
Do you see this?
Oh,
punching the guy who said that he didn't
go to.
I know that guy.
That Guy Bart cerebral that he punched.
I went to the moon landing tonight.
Oh yeah.
Alex Jones.
I used to be a moon landing denier.
I used to believe.
I used to believe totally that we never
went to the moon because there was a
documentary that came on Fox.
Yes.
Trust me.
No,
I didn't,
I didn't go to number four in the 19
nineties in the 19 nineties,
Fox had a show called conspiracy theory.
Did we go to the moon and they aired it
on television,
prime time.
They got me hook,
line and sinker,
and for years I believe that we didn't
go to the Mon.
What changed you?
Mostly talking to neil degrasse tyson,
but also critical thinking.
Also realizing that I Was fully
committed to that idea without really
exploring the possibility whether that
idea was incorrect and that I would take
in everything that I saw in that
documentary,
which is incredibly convincing and with
100 percent confirmation bias,
I only looked at that and I didn't look
at all the contrary evidence.
There's some fucked up stuff about the
moon landing unfortunately.
And the fucked up stuff is mostly people
that were involved in publicity that
we're doing stupid things with
photographs.
Like they had taken a picture of,
I'm going into unchartered territory or
just say like,
you're an expert on this.
I've never gotten into landing.
Denialism
was buzz aldrin.
Um,
who was the guy that was Michael
Collins?
Michael collins in gemini 15
photographs.
He seen it many times.
Pulled up that photo.
This is what I'm talking about.
No,
no,
no.
It has nothing to do with that.
This is a photo that they,
uh,
they put out as an official photograph
of Michael Collins doing a spacewalk,
but what it actually is,
is a photo of them testing equipment and
they blacked out the backgrouNd.
So he's in this suit that they were
doing with testing and instead,
because they really couldn't get good
photos in space because no one's out
there with him taking his pictures.
Right.
So they lied.
They faked it.
This is it.
So the see the one on the left,
you see the real photograph and this is
him in a studio where they're working on
him or warehouse rather or some sort of
a testing environment working on how to
control these harnesses that you would
use when you're on a space walk because
that thing propels him forward and back
and he's learning how to use it.
What they did was they just blacked out
the background and reversed it and then
they sold that as him actually being in
space.
So this is probably an overzealous
publicists and there's a bunch of these.
There's a bunch of these when it comes
to different backgrounds in areas of the
moon,
there are many,
many miles apart from each other.
It shouldn't be the same background and
more likely than not what you're dealing
with is overzealous publicist because
photographs were incredibly difficult to
get.
I'm sure.
Well,
the morAl of the story to me,
thank god first of all that you're no
longer a moon landing denier,
but also the power of the media and the
press and like you saw one documentary,
right?
There's a couple after I saw that.
Quite a few,
but that sent you down this rabbit hole
and that,
you know,
I've been thinking about.
Did you see that roku is,
I think d platformed.
Info wars,
yes.
Instantly,
like within a day.
But I wanted to ask you a question
before we get.
Okay.
Because I have to say I feel.
I think I support that because
I don't want like in an age in which
people don't know,
okay,
like a 15 year old clicking through
their roku doesn't necessarily know the
difference between cnn and info wars and
the New York times and msnbc and
whatever,
and of course some of those other ones
have biases obviously,
but info wars promotes conspiracy
theories and do I want a 15 year old kid
stumbling into that and thinking that
that information is on par on a level
with actual facts
fix.
The problem with conspiracy theories is
that some of them are real.
This is the real problem.
The problem is you don't know which ones
are real,
but some of them are real.
The gulf of tonkin that got us into the
Vietnam war.
You're aware of that?
Okay,
but sandy hook,
sandy hook for sure happened.
Bunch of kids died and these are
horrible.
These are horrible evil conspiracies.
The problem is loaded by Alex Jones.
Yes.
It's horrible.
Without a doubt,
and I saw the media matters clip that
I'd never seen before.
I saw it recently.
When you clip the one that shows every
time he brought it up.
Oh,
amazing.
How just one time.
Oh,
I know many,
many,
many tImes and was saying it was an
absolutely fake thing.
Has he ever apologize backed off of the
position now?
But I think because of the lawsuit or
I'm sure it's a lot of things.
I'm sure it's the pressure.
It sorts.
It has to be a realization that he knows
that it really did happen,
but there's a giant group of people out
there that still believe it didn't
happen and they still confront these
parents even in court and they call them
crisis.
No,
I know that the time.
it's done.
Amazing reporting on this.
Elizabeth Williamson.
Mild sick.
It's sick.
It's twisted.
Um,
we probably shouldn't.
I mean we can go into conspiracy
theories.
I just don't know to go into.
It's not a bad thing to go into because
it's a thing.
Okay.
But it's,
it's,
you know.
I'm curious what you think drove around.
what do you think of roku taking info
wars up?
Oh,
I think we have to decide what,
what is twitter?
What is facebook?
What is youtube?
The position that most people have is
these are private companies.
They can make their own rules.
This is just like cbs deciding that if
you use a,
you know,
if you drunkenly yell the n word out at
a black police officer,
that they don't want you as a newscaster
anymore.
What,
you know,
that's a public account or a private
company that can make these
distinctions.
If you take a position,
uh,
an antisemitic position publicly,
they can,
they can decide,
look,
we don't want you on the air anymore.
And then there's other people that think
freedom of speech in this form is so
important and that the answer to bad
ideas is not stopping those ideas.
It's good ideas.
It's good ideas confronting those ideas
and you see it all work itself out.
That's,
that's the does the other side of the
coin.
That's the other side of the argument.
The argument that we should treat,
whether it's twitter or youtube or any
of these social media platforms as a
public utility and they,
you should be able to distribute
information.
The real problem is with all of this,
is that it's very messy.
The,
the,
there's,
this is a nuanced issue.
There's a lot going on because when you
do decide to deep platform someone for
having an awful position and spreading a
false conspiracy about that,
most people are gonna agree with you,
but the question is,
does it stop there and does it move on
to you are a person who believes in
white nationalism.
What does that mean?
Well,
I believe that black pride is fine,
but I also believe white pride is fine.
What about those people?
Where do we go with them?
Then it gets slippery and then jason.
Yeah,
jason,
I met people that have given the
outright of platform,
you know,
what are they,
are they a part of the problem now?
Should we d platform them?
I mean,
this is one of the things that,
there was a,
uh,
a paper that someone had put together an
article that was
hilarious where it's like everyone has
this very bizarre connection.
It's six degrees of kevin bacon.
Yes,
exactly.
And but,
but they're using yet in terms of the
way the connections is almost,
if it's scientific data,
well they would basically say have you
or something like.
Well they did say to me,
they said,
have you,
you're a gateway to the outright.
Yes.
So what I said is Barbara Walters
interviewed castro.
Does that make her a communist?
What the fuck are you talking about?
Exactly.
pretty left.
Like,
just ask me questions.
Like if you want to know I'm not going
to hide my positions on things from you.
I,
I'm very open.
Obviously.
I've told people I used to believe the
moon landing was fake.
I'll tell you all the stupid shit I
believed,
but
the question with this is it,
why do people want that?
because it's simple and easy.
Just get them,
get rid of them,
punch them,
punch the nazis.
It's lazy,
stupid people thinking and they're
thinking publicly and they,
uh,
they represent a progressive viewpoint
with their lazy,
stupid thinking.
It's not that progressivism and
progressive viewpoints or bad is that
lazy,
stupid thinking.
And applying a progressive viewpoint is
bad.
It's not even that socialism is bad.
I've been thinking a lot about socialism
lately in terms of like what is the
point if if we get to a certain point
and then our our hot,
our heart stops beating and we dye it
and you,
you left behind $18,
billion dollars to your kids because you
were the ultimate capitalist and you
went hog wild.
That sets a fool's path.
That Is a nonsense path.
Like why did you do that?
like why didn't you try to use that
money,
this insane amount of wealth and have
this massive impact on,
on the populous?
Why?
Why didn't you try to figure out some
way?
Right?
It wouldn't be a choice to but what if
bill gates right now,
but what if this bill gates is doing
that and a lot of ways with some of the
money tomorrow if he throws a million
here or there,
it really ain't shit for him and he's
gotten like $90,000,000,000,
whatever it is.
But the point is that things like the
fire department,
we agree this is a socialist thing,
right?
We were all chip in.
We have public utilities,
we have people that parks and
recreation,
people that are department of fish and
wildlife and the sheriffs that patrol
our national forest.
We all chip in to pay for these things.
We all agree these are important thIngs.
Well,
one of the things that was so
interesting about Australia is that in
certain ways it's a more,
you know,
it's thought of as sort of a macho
culture,
maybe more masculine,
a little bit more conservative than here
generally,
and yet the left has one.
There are so many of the major issues
that we're fighting.
We're killing each other over now.
They're very universal healthcare.
Yeah.
mandatory 401k
$18 minimum wage pensions,
four weeks of vacation a year.
Like I think they get maternity leave as
well.
It's just like so many of the things
that are up for grabs,
they already solved.
I think we have to take things into
consideration.
One that they have a small population,
small in homogenous in its enormous
place.
You're dealing with a place as large as
the contiguous United States of America,
but there's only 20 million people on
way because when they were like,
it's crowded in that restaurant,
and I was like,
you mean I don't have to wait for an
hour to get in?
They,
no,
they've never seen a crowd of people.
They don't know what a real crowd is.
And also I think their culture
is less constrained by history because
they came,
they were essentially prisoners.
I mean
several generations removed.
Exactly.
Yeah.
But it's not,
not only that they're not indigenous.
No.
I mean like the non indigenous
population prisoners.
Yes.
Yeah,
well they came from,
they were sent there because england and
warm and that's literally how the
country got founded for like stealing a
watch.
Like they were low level.
Then they sent them to the much better
place.
Oh yeah.
Way better.
It's,
I'm a gold coast.
You're like,
holy shit.
It just takes forever to get fewer
manchester.
It's raining everyday,
like fuck this place
and you,
you know,
you stole a watch and they shipped you
off to the gold coast.
She be like,
what?
What just happened?
This is hilarious.
Your fish out here.
It's fucking beautiful.
They're nice
people and I,
I wonder if they're so nice.
I feel like they are slightly less nice
than canadians who are way more nice
than us.
I think that's right.
I also think that they have.
They have it so good that they're a
little complacent and that makes me
concerned because China.
Okay.
Right.
That's the big story there.
Yes.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
that is to be considered,
but I think the United States,
first of all,
we have this momentum of innovation and
of ass kicking and,
and,
and getting things done and creating
things that's so different than any
other part of the world.
If we took that shit down a notch,
I think we'd be okay.
You know,
I mean I think we definitely do have to
worry about China and know I've been
really trying to closely follow all this
walway stuff where these executives keep
getting arrested and you know,
It's the close relationship between some
tech companies and this communist
government is very confusing,
but some people look it over.
So if you talk to people that are
chinese natives or who have been to
China,
they almost look at as a positive.
There's less resistance.
It's more.
Even though the censorship is open,
it's at least you know what you're
dealing with over there as opposed to,
you know,
the nsa is spiraling up.
Oh,
I don't buy It at all,
but it's,
I've seen some people make that
argument.
It's horrifying.
It's weird.
it's horrifying.
So I agree.
I agree with you.
You do have to worry about China,
but I think Australia is like,
ah,
it's fucking americans take care of it.
So they think sorta,
except like their situation is that
they're enormously economic.
They're enormously dependent on China
economically and they love having that
money,
but they seem to be a little bit like
sleep walking through history and not is
at least some people that I spoke to it,
but that's.
That's the real story in Australia is
China.
Well,
I think
when you're not a military might,
you know,
you're not like one of the big players.
you're kind of like sitting back
watching because what are we going to
do?
Like what if Australia decides to ramp
up its defense budget by 5,000 percent
over the next 10 years and develop a
crazy arsenal of weapons and super
soldiers and shoot them all off the
steroids,
give them exoskeletons and get ready to
go to war,
start building bunkers and freak the
rest of the world out and take this like
North Korea with money approach the
world in North Korea with money.
Well,
norTh Korea is basically like this scary
spot that nobody wants to invade even
though we know that there's a military
dictatorship there.
They have their weapons,
we have nuclear weapons,
they have a madman who's in control.
They have people that escaped with
horrific stories and we have a president
who talks about them as if they're sort
of a normal country.
Yeah.
Well the weird thing is like he might be
able to sit down with them and actually
talked to them is his unconventional
approach might actually lead to some
sort of communication at least.
Which is better than nothing I guess,
but.
But if.
I don't mean like in North Korea,
like they take over the country and in
prison it's people.
I mean like they're,
they become kind of dangerous and
sketchy and small.
Like North Korea is not a military dick
power.
Like in terms of like the way the soviet
union is where they could take over the
world,
but they're scared but they're
untouchable.
Yeah,
exactly.
If Australia became that,
then I think we have a totally different
attitude about Australia.
Australia,
Australia is just laid back and they're
like,
hey,
americans take arabic and then we're
over here building fucking walls and
shooting missiles.
Yeah.
I would imagine it would be really weird
to watch us from afar if you were paying
attention to world politics
because they know everything.
I mean,
everyone I talked to there was like,
let's talk about gerrymandering in
Virginia,
and I'm like,
what are you saying?
They have to follow what's going on here
in ways that I found kind of amazing,
like genuinely actually gerrymandering
in Virginia.
I was like,
there,
don't you have the news going on for a
year?
If the answer is sort of note.
YeAh.
Comedians move over there.
They move over there and become huge in
Australia.
Shout out to my friend,
judge barker.
He's out there.
It's huge.
Gigantic over there.
Like a lot of people don't know him here
in Australia.
He's like jerry seinfeld,
huge,
enormous sells a huge auditoriums,
but that's because when a giant american
celebrity comes over,
they're just going to sell out
everything because that's the only game
in town.
No,
he's not a giant american celebrity.
He's an australian celebratory seinfeld.
No barker.
I thought we're talking about jerry
seinfeld.
I'm like,
oh yeah,
I know you're into like alternative
media platform that I think people know
seinfeld.
It's no arch barker.
I'd never heard of him.
There you go.
He's here to Australia.
When I talked to australians and they're
like,
oh,
you stand up comedian,
you know odg bucket.
They're gonna be mad at me like Adam
Green.
She's gonna.
Be pissed.
Right.
That fucking australian accents.
Terrible brow.
It is bad.
It's not good.
I don't even try.
But have you been following the women's
march stuff at all or no?
Yes.
Yes I have.
Yeah,
the uh,
antisemitic stuff.
Yeah.
Fucking groups.
You know when you have a group,
you have a group of people and then you
have.
That was a little bit to me as related
to the,
what happened at the lincoln memorial,
right?
Where you had these,
you know,
the leadership of the women's march,
which looked like a shepard fairey
poster come to life.
Like they were just perfect.
You had linda sarsour and her hijab
behind tamika mallory.
what's going on is that back in August,
2017,
I wrote a column called wouldn't
progressive's embrace hate,
and it was saying I was super moved by
the women's march as so many other
women.
I know we're,
but let's look at some of the very
troubling ideas and associations that
the people who are in charge of the
leadership of the women's march have,
namely the worst of the worst was tamika
mallory,
who'd been in gun rights activists
beforehand.
She called louis farrakhan the goat,
the greatest of all time.
She took lots of instagram pictures.
You should check this,
but she praised him.
It wasn't like a casual acquaintance.
She praised him as the greatest of all
time and yet she was treated to glowing
profiles in every women's magazine,
her and the rest of the leadership.
And I basically said like,
let's look past,
you know,
the benetton ad of these leaders and
actually look at what they believe and
what they believe.
Some of them is extremely disturbing,
especially when it comes to jews say,
write this column.
And I'm like pilloried for it.
By the left.
One of the leaders of the women's march,
this woman bob bland,
wrote this letter to the New York times
where she calls me,
um,
it was amazing.
I want to find what it was.
Oh,
she calls me an apologist for the status
quo,
racist ideology and the white
nationalist patriarchy because you
responded to someone because I said
greatest of all time is a man who called
judaism termites who calls juice
termites,
who calls judaism a gutter religion,
who says that we should burn in ovens
and who by the way is a massage and
homophobe also the leaders of the
women's march or associating with this
guy and had the nation of islam security
protecting them.
I mean this is Like the most sort of
retro grade hate group and yet for
calling them out,
I was called all of these things
flies.
That's a deep question.
I think that part of it is the fact that
in intersectional leftwing politics,
jews have been whitewashed.
Jews are viewed as sort of the white
privileged power and part of the white
patriarchy and less.
They genuflect and say,
actually,
no,
we,
you know,
we have poor our privilege and all of
the other things that you're supposed to
say,
and there's a blIndness to the fact
great,
and there's a blindness to the fact that
first of all,
not jews are white.
Half of the jews in the state of Israel,
for example,
are arab and from arab countries that
they were kicked out of a 19,
48.
I mean the idea that jews are white is
this canard.
Although I'm an ashkenazi jew,
I'm my family is from eastern europe.
I have white skin but I don't think of,
and I have white privilege,
but I don't think of myself as white
person.
I think of myself as a jew first and
foremost,
so it's a complicated identity,
but I think that it's sort of a.
It's whitewashed by these people and I
think that antisemitism just isn't taken
seriously and doesn't rate because
people perceive jews as having privilege
and power in this country,
which largely they do.
But the fact is is that the actual
statistics show that more hate crimes
were committed against jews in the past
year than any other minority group.
The fbi's like sounding the alarm every
other day in crown heights and in other
parts of brooklyn,
random jews who looked jewish,
right?
Who were hasidic.
Jews are just beaten up for being
jewish.
and yet everyone's ignoring that because
they're the imperfect victim will.
They're also very isolated.
They're very.
They have their own tribe.
They stick with them,
they look different,
they dress different.
Sure.
But imagine if any other minority group,
someone.
I mean,
we're outraged when we see at least i
am.
And you are.
When we see a police officer assaulting
someone,
you know what I'm saying is the young
black person,
they don't make a big deal to go into
the public about it.
They keep it almost insulated inside
their environment and their community.
There's also,
what I was going to say is that these
people that are,
that you do here saying antisemitic
things,
they're equating american jews living in
America with the policies of Israel and
what Israel is doing with palestine.
And that somehow if you're an american
jew,
even if you're not even political,
you're somehow or another complicit with
atrocities that are going on between the
jewish people and the palestinians,
right?
Conflict,
any kind of conflict.
And this makes it.
It reinforces their idea about you being
a part of this group.
Yes,
but they also straw men it and say,
criticism of Israel is an antisemitic.
No one's saying that criticism isn't of
Israel antisemitic.
I criticize Israel at the time,
but there's an obsession on the state of
Israel.
Like if you were an alien that landed
from outer space,
you would think that the greatest
oppressor in the world is this tiny
state that's the size of New Jersey.
These people say nothing about the genet
generally about the genocide of weger
muslims in China.
They say nothing about any number of
even aware that,
oh,
there's a genocide going on,
carried out by the government of China
against weaker muslims.
They're literally being put into
concentration camps.
This is literally a first.
I've heard of this.
So [inaudible] is spelled you I g,
h,
you are.
Whereas a,
what is a good thing to read about the
New York times that we've reported on
it,
it's a,
it's an enormous story and it's like the
fact that that's getting know that you
don't know about it and that people
obsessive talk about the state of Israel
is if it's the and by the way the state
of Israel does lots of things wrong,
but the idea that it's among the worst
human rights tragedies of our time.
Are you kidding me?
It's insanity.
I don't know the reality of what is
going on in gaza.
I don't know what is happening with
Israel and palestine.
I don't know,
so I'm not going to be the person that
talks about this,
but what I do know some stuff to read,
but I do know from people that have gone
there like abby martin,
who,
who came back with some pretty horrific
stories.
I think there's a lot of terrible shit
going on.
There's a lot of awful violence and
there's a lot of despair on the side of
the palestinians and I don't.
I don't know who's to blame for that,
but many people blame the israelis.
They blame the israelis for treating the
palestinians as if they're in this one
area of the world is essentially a large
prison.
Well,
lots to say about this,
but I think one of the main problems
that we have in the way that Israel is
covered is that if you have a camera
lens and you're only looking at a tiny
piece of land,
right,
you're only looking at Israel proper.
The west bank and gaza,
Israel to some extent is the goliath in
that situation,
but if you zoom out your camera just a
little,
you see that Israel is literally
surrounded on all sides by genocidal
regimes like in the form of hamas in
gaza,
whose charter blamed the jews for
fomenting that.
The french revolutions,
the russian revolutions,
both world wars and says that it wants
to kill all the jews.
That's what.
That's the government of gaza right now.
I spoke to a mother who fled gaza
recently.
okay.
And her family's house was just
destroyed.
Who was it destroyed by?
Hamas,
not Israel.
You never hear those storIes.
So I'm just saying it is a very
complicated
politics,
but when you see people obsessively
focusing on this one state and the
crimes of this one state to the
exclusion of actual dictatorships in the
world who are killing their own people,
you have to be suspicious of that.
You do have to be suspicious and you do
have to be aware of their position in
the world surrounded by arab states.
When you do have to realize that they
are there,
they're alone out there.
You also,
I do wonder,
what is the motivation for so many
people focusing on jews?
What is it like?
What do you think it is as a jewish
person?
What do you think the motivation for
this kind of racism and discrimination
against jews and why is it tolerated?
Why?
Why can someone like louis farrakhan
tweet that jews are in
his twitter account,
stays up.
It's the olDest hatred in the world,
right?
a lot of exam what it is.
No,
no,
no.
You're asking me why is it still with
us?
It's like the mystery of history like
that is.
That is deep.
I mean,
that is something that goes back to the
new testament.
Okay.
The jews were blamed in the book of john
and mark.
I mean,
we could go to matthew for the death of
jesus.
Their role in that story,
at least according to some of the books,
is that they convinced the most powerful
empire at the time,
the roman empire in the form of the
governor of judea,
punches pilot to kill the son of god.
That becomes sort of the template for
the antisemitic conspiracy theory.
There's,
there's a confusion about what
antisemitism is,
right?
It's not just a hate.
It's not just like this.
Hate of a group racist perceived
themselves as punching down against a
group that's lesser antisemites perceive
themselves as punching up against the
secret cabal of wildly operators who
secretly controlled the leavers of
power.
That is the canard of antisemitism,
and that begins with this group that's
able somehow to get the roman empire to
kill jesus.
Now,
the catholic church disavows this in
1965,
which was an enormous historical event,
but that template is still there and you
see it play out right in who?
Who led us into the war in Iraq,
it was the jews of the bush
administration.
You can see it play itself out all over
the place and right now in the
demonology of current contemporary
antisemitism,
Israel has sort of been made into the
jew among the nations.
You're not allowed to say anymore.
It's like the old school antisemitism,
right?
Like I grew up in a place where there
was some country clubs where jews
couldn't go into them.
That frankly,
that's not dangerous.
What's dangerous is the kind of
antisemitism that says,
you know,
this one state in the world of all of
the,
almost 200 states,
that's the one that doesn't have the
right to exist.
That's the one that should be
dismantled.
That's actually dangerous to jewish
lives right now.
It is.
Um,
it's an unusual group in that it is both
a religion and a tribe.
Yes.
It makes us very hard to understand in
the contemporary landscape because we
are not just a religion.
There's nothing else like it.
Because most jews that I know do not
practice judaism.
Right.
And yet they choose us because we were a
people hood before we were a religion.
Religion is a very contemporary,
modern thing that jews are sort of
slotted into and it makes us easier to
understand.
But then our,
our sort of national identity or
peoplehood,
our tribalism is left out and that's an
essential part of who the jews are.
My friend ari shaffir,
who's a fantastic stand up comedian,
he's a rabid atheists,
but he's also very jewish and he has a
new hour that he's working on right now
that is going to film called jew.
I want to see it,
but he's,
you know,
he's a perfect example is a tribe.
It's not just a religion,
but it's also because the jewish
religion itself,
the emphasis,
the emphasis is not on what you believe.
The emphasis is on deeds.
It almost doesn't matter what you
believe.
It matters that you follow,
hahaha.
Which is jewish law matters your deeds.
It matters all these things.
So it's possible to be a good jew and
not really think about god that much,
which is very strange.
I understand.
To christian ears or you go full ben
shapiro where he's both a good jew and
very much like follows the whole deal
the whole deal,
the whole deal.
Um.
Why do you say that?
I think.
Sorry,
can I say one more place?
I just find it like kind of astonishing
the blindness to this because imagine a
leader of the women's march said
something like,
you know,
I think louis ck is the greatest
comedian of all time even though I
disavow x,
y,
and z thing that he did.
How fast to let person was kicked out of
the leadership of the women's march.
It would be like minutes hours.
Yes.
I think there are certain things that
get people outraged and other much worse
things that do not.
And I'm fascinated by why that is.
Do you think that if it was a white
person that had this opinion about the
jews,
that it would be more scrutinized?
I think thAt it is much easier to fight
antisemitism when it comes in the form
of Richard Spencer.
Yes.
Because then there's liberal consensus,
right?
About him.
He's have a green light to criticize.
It is much harder when,
when an an.
Exactly.
it's much harder when someone like ilhan
omar,
the new freshman senator.
Uh,
sorry.
Not senator,
the new freshman congresswoman for
Minnesota who's like this incredible
american dream story comes here at 12
years old,
refugee from Somalia,
wears a hijab,
is a mother,
is the first woman of color representing
Minnesota.
Like obviously I want to cheer her.
That's my reaction to her and yet she
has this tweet that she refused to
apologize is four where she says,
Israel is hypnotize.
The world may all awake in the world to
the evil doings of Israel.
I'm sorry.
That's a classically antiseMitic trope.
Even if she said it unwittingly and by
this point she should have known she
should eduCate herself.
So it's very,
it's much harder to criticize that,
but it's,
it's an untenable position to say that
you can't criticize someone for their
ideas because of their identity.
It also seems like a road to nowhere
you're going to say that.
That is a very vague thing to say.
You should be incredibly specific.
Have you want to say it's evil,
you should say what's evil and then open
that up to some sort of a discussion or
debate,
but as describing supernatural evil
powers to a state is very much recalling
classic antisemetic canards.
Right.
So with that I read,
I wrote a piece about this today,
trying to like explain that to people
because she went on cnn saying,
I don't know how jewish americans could
be offended by this,
which I think is incredible.
Cool.
Yeah.
What do you think if.
I mean,
if you want to be objective as I mean
step outside of your jewish identity,
what do you think is wrong with how
Israel is dealing with the palestinian
situation?
Because this is the big criticisM of
Israel.
The only criticism really that's the big
one.
The big one is gaza and palestine.
So what do you think they're doing
wrong?
Palestine meaning the west bank?
Yes.
Well,
I would say what the untenable position
that they're in is that they are
oCcupying another people.
That is what is going on in the west
bank and I've been there many times,
met with many palestinians.
I've really educated myself on this.
The problem is is that,
and by the way,
it's not all of palestine.
There's all the west bank,
there's areas a,
b and c.
It's a really like we'd have to pull up
a map.
It's a pretty complicated thinG.
There are places where it's much more
autonomous and the pa's in charge and
it,
it really varies depending on the area,
so the big criticism,
right is that they're occupying and
other people and that is corrosive to
the state of Israel,
sort of morally like to,
to occupy and other people.
On the other hand,
what happens if they pull out of the
west bank tomorrow?
Right.
I'm for a two state solution ultimately
ending the occupation,
but if I'm real,
I have to be honest about what that
would look like.
WHat would it look like in gaza?
Is that now you have a terrorist state
lit right at the border which is ruled
by hamas.
It is quite likely that that very same
thing could happen in the west bank.
Now let's say actually we actually
should pull up a map.
Let's say Israel does that.
Then like the whole of Israel proper is
something like we have to look two miles
wide.
We actually,
yeah,
we should look at the,
the distance between like tool car,
um,
or like the end of the west bank and
natanya or tel aviv and you see how
small that is.
I mean it's hard to even conceive of it
if you were in charge of Protecting the
security of the people who live in
places,
which by the way,
10 years ago when in the year after high
school when I was living there,
there were suicide bombings blowing up
in cafes around the corner from where I
lived.
Or you going to subject those people to
that risk.
I mean that's the,
that's the actual question facing the
government of Israel,
which by the way,
I'm extremely critical of and if I lived
in Israel,
I'd be voting center left in Israel for
sure,
but that is what they're facing.
And then if you zoom out and you pull up
a map of all of the countries around it,
I just want to look.
Sorry.
No,
iT's okay.
Actually the one you were on was good
because it showed if you zoomed out it
had everything,
so you have Egypt there,
then you have Jordan,
which is teetering,
then you Syria,
then you of Lebanon and hIs bellows on
the southern border of Lebanon,
which is constantly,
you know,
so that's the real thing.
So when people talk about this fantasy
of why can't it just look like America,
why can't there just be a democratic one
state solution?
First of all,
no one wants it.
They pull people constantly.
But the second thing is like step really
what that's gonna look like if we
dismantle the state of Israel or is it
going to look like enormous bloodshed?
The likes of which we see in a lot of
these countries surrounding it.
Like someone once said to me that if you
want to know the word for,
you know,
a jew without a military,
it's the [inaudible].
Okay.
It's these eds.
It's the people.
It's the minorities in the middle east
who had been absolutely
destroyed and overrun.
ANd this is like,
it's.
I don't think when americans talk about
this part of the world,
they fully appreciate this sort of
absolutely painful and hard decisions
and the grappling with violence really,
you know,
what happened to jamal [inaudible] shogi
and that saudi embassy that's like
normative for this part of the world.
So the fact that Israel has somehow with
all of its flaws,
managed to eke out a western style
liberal democracy,
frankly the only place where you and I
would feel happy and comfortable living.
Like,
why are we never talking about that?
Well,
I think it's very difficult for people
to find the forum,
to discuss it the way you just did and
to to really lay it out in cold,
stark reality.
What is the solution?
There is no magic.
The solution right now is to do
everything possible to build up the
palestinian economy to for Israel to
build relationships.
Like right now,
it has a very,
very positive relationships with Egypt,
which gave back the sinai,
which had had one in the six day,
six day war,
I believe,
gave it back to Egypt for a cold piece,
which it's had,
it has a good relationship of all
things.
Who would have thought with Saudi Arabia
because of their common enemy?
Iran.
I mean things shift.
They're rapidly,
um,
but,
but as for the palestinians,
the solution is to build up the economy,
make life better and support people and
movements inside the west bank that are
genuinely nonviolent.
And those people exist.
It's just frankly,
oftentimes they're murdered by groups
like hamas and their bodies are dragged
through the streets.
If you're accused of being an israeli
collaborator in the west bank,
you know what happens to you,
your lynched?
No one talks about that.
No,
no one does talk about that.
What would you be open to discussing
this in this sort of a form with that
woman from the women's march a.
Sure.
Do you think she would do something like
that?
I don't know.
I'd be open to it.
Do you think that people like her have
ever had a conversation with someone
like you who could lay it out?
No,
because I think that first of all,
many people who talk about this issue
have sort of exported aMerican domestic
politics to a foreign region of the
world.
Like in a way that this is talked about
a lot.
It's like the oppressor,
the oppressed,
the white,
the blaCk.
No,
that's not what's going on.
I don't think people understand when
they talk about israeli jews that half
of them are middle eastern,
like half of israeli jews are arab,
you know,
there's no appreciation of that reality.
They think that Israel was just founded,
you know,
to save the remnant of the jews who
weren't destroyed in the holocaust and
yeah,
it helped for those who survived,
but then once the state of Israel was
established,
there was a mass exodus of the jews from
all of the arab countries where they had
been living as second class citizens
where they are either self deported
because they were living at as second
class citizens or they were expelled.
again,
that exodus,
that deportation never talked about.
I'd be happy to talk about this with
someone from the women's march.
What is the,
what is the response currently like
what,
what?
What is the current position that most
people were taking about that woman and
about the woman's march in general
because of these things because of these
analysts,
antisemitic statements.
I think a lot of people in the past few
weeks,
thanks in part to meghan mccain,
had five minutes on the view with tamika
mallory and bob land and she did an
amazing job grilling them on the view.
The view is what's changed?
It's amazing.
I know,
but she did an amazing job because,
because frankly because their image was
so powerful in the same way that the
image of the lincoln memorial was so
powerful,
journalists just sort of accepted it and
didn't interrogate that.
Who doesn't want to support that?
But it's our job to be skeptical and
criticize.
Right?
So I think finally a lot of people woke
up to it.
Um,
but again,
I wrote that column in August,
2017 and it took until now everything in
that column is the thing people are
talking about.
There was also an amazing 10,000 word
expos and tablet magazine and jewish
online magazine that did a lot of that
work,
so I think it did reach a tipping point.
The thing that is,
um,
I see a lot of my friends on the left
who are jewish grappling with is that
they so desperately want to be a part of
these movements that they're willing to
sort of check their identity at the door
in order to gain entry.
And my thing is any progressive movement
that's asking you to check your jewish
identity at the door,
your full jewish identity,
which is acknowledging that we're not
just a faith,
but we're at people.
We're not just people that like have
matzah ball soup or something bigger
than that.
That's not a space I want to be a part
of.
They would never ask that.
If any other group.
Why us?
Why?
Why do they ask that?
That,
that,
that's what the real question.
I really think.
Well,
no,
I think a lot of it goes back to what I
was saying before,
which is this misunderstanding if you
see the world in an intersectional way.
Okay,
not is intersectionality was originally
meant to be,
but how it functions in the world,
it functions as a caste system and the
higher you are on the victim scale,
at least on the left and it's reversed
on the right,
right on the right.
It's like white,
cis gendered men are at the top on the
left there at the bottom and the jews or
somewhere close down to there at least
in the way that the left the left.
I mean this part of the left,
we're talking about the fringe at least
for now.
Perceive the jews to be the woke left.
Yeah.
The jews are not.
The jews don't rate.
The jews don't have a place in that
victim scale because they have achieved
so much success because they can pass as
white because of any number of things
and so I think that that's a huge reason
for it,
which is a huge reason why I think
intersectionality is a dead end and why
we need to be talking about ideas and
not identity.
Right.
Like that.
That is the thing about America that is
so amazing and like,
I know it sounds cheesy,
but I really feel it.
That makes us so special.
We are not a country based on blood and
soil.
We are a country whose national common
identity is based on ascribing to a
common set of ideas.
That is what we're about and so any
politics that's insisting from the left
or the right that no,
actually what we are is this warring set
of groups competing for scarce
resources?
Absolutely not.
To me,
those kinds of politics are unamerican.
I couldn't agree more in terms of
identity.
I think identity politics and the idea
that you belong to a group is so
intoxicating but so dangerous.
It'S so important to treat people as
individuals.
It's so important to think of yourself
as an individual and this,
this need to become a part of this group
in a signal to that group is a big part
of the problem that we're having right
now
and it doesn't mean that you can't have
pride.
Like I have tremendous pride the most in
being a jew and like jonathan heit talks
so brilliantly about good identity
politics and bad identity politics that
good identity politics says,
walk with me in my shoes.
It's like a big tent sort of thing.
It says,
come along with me while I explained to
you my experience in the world that
identity politics says you can never
escape the gender of the racial,
the economic lane you were born into and
don't even try and understand me because
you couldn't possibly.
That's bad.
Identity politics and I think that
that's enforced and rising right now in
the country.
and I think that that's dangerous and
I've been thinking about it a lot
because it's martin luther king day and
he said this unbelievable thing about.
I think it's actually in the.
I had a dream speech,
but where he talks about the,
the promissory note of the constitution
and the declaration of independence,
right?
That these people who wrote it,
who were slave owners didn't even know
that in writing it.
That every american was going to fall
heir to this promissory note.
And it's like he saw himself even in
documents that were written by people
who would not have seen them as fully
human as a way of sort of using that
common set of values,
those common documents to like write
himself into the story.
Like that is an example of,
uh,
of,
of inclusive identity politics and like
calling on the thing that we have in
common too wide in the tent.
And I just don't see a lot of that
happening these days.
I really butchered that.
But everyone should look up to,
you know,
I did.
If you look up,
jonathan heit gave a speech,
I think you can find the whole text of
it at city journal.
Um,
but if you just look up jonathan heit,
good identity politics,
martin luther king,
he does an amazing job.
It's,
it's really moving
his book,
the happiness hypothesis.
I'm,
I'm in the middle of it right now.
It's so good.
It's so fantastic.
It's so crucial for people that want to
understand their own personal biases and
what's coming and saying he's amazing.
He was on here last week.
I thought he was incredible.
He is the,
the,
the idea of having pride in something
is,
is interesting,
right?
You know,
there's a lot of people that have pride
for their ethnicity,
although they had nothing to do with,
with choosing it.
It's just something that they're born
with.
I think people get nervous about that
kind of pride,
but I think there should be a settling.
It would be wonderful if we could keep
all of these cultures and yet all
appreciate each other as equals.
It'd be wonderful if you could go and
eat ethiopian food one day or cuban food
the next day and they,
these people exist in the small.
That's the beauty of this.
Now.
You can right now you can,
but as we get more and more homogenized,
I wonder if you will be able to
wait more homogenized or more insistent
on you have to stay in your lane.
There's both,
both things.
I think we're definitely cooking off the
bacteria as well.
Where we're wearing homogenization is
where we're making things safer and
easier for everybody and you know,
there's some messiness,
messiness to cultures exchanging with
each other,
but it is also fantastic.
Very excited
to say I loved Australia,
but when I get off that plane and I
landed at like a shitty as they are at
jfk or laguardia and I see like every
kind of human being on the planet,
you know,
and like I walk everyday from I live,
um,
I live in manhattan and I walked to
work.
They are in bag everyday.
It just helps me decompress and the kind
of like the diversity of people on the
sidewalk of midtown manhattan.
It's amazing.
I find it to be the most exciting thing
in the world and the fact that we're
able to live amongst such difference and
not kill each other.
Angeles is what drives,
you know,
you don't have that or you drive there.
I love it heRe,
but that's why I couldn't live here.
Well no one walks.
Everyone's locked in together in their.
They Stay in their neighborhood and they
drive out to go somewhere else and they
don't even interact with each other on
the street.
One of the things about the subway in,
one of the things about walking on the
street is everybody's together.
Everyone's Together.
And there's this,
this interesting melting pot of human
beings that exist in New York.
It doesn't exist anywhere else in that
form.
Like boston is so much more white.
It's so much more.
I mean there's a lot of ethnicities and.
But it's,
it's not the same.
New york is fucking flavorful.
There's a lot of shit going on.
It's a lot of great parts to it.
It's also what concerns me is that
people in New York are uniquely hostile.
And then.
Yeah,
for sure,
very nice.
But a lot of people that I'm even
friends with from New York,
I'm like,
you mother fuckers are stacked on top of
each other too much.
You like you,
you don'T.
People aren't unique.
Like would it be fair?
I'm from pittsburgh.
So you might be getting that like
midwestern flavor.
I bet that's exactly what it is,
is pittsburgh's different.
Little more relaxed,
leSs people have to count on each other
more and fucking snow gets you.
It gets rough out there.
You know,
it's not like you're,
you're not in a city the same way.
It's not.
You got to drive places so different,
you know.
That is very midwest,
pittsburgh,
very midwest,
nice place.
I like pittsburgh,
but New York,
I love New York,
but New York always makes me feel like
when you have that many people slammed
on top of each other,
you're in this completely unnatural
environment that literally has never
existed in human nature up until a few
hundred years ago.
Never happened like that and now it's
unprecedented because there's more and
more people there that just buzzing and
they're putting these buildings up.
We've.
You've got 100 floors.
My friend jim norton talks about it all
the time because he lives in a building
because I don't know a fucking person in
my building.
Thousand people in the spirit living in
a building like that.
I could never live in a high rise
building.
It freaks me out too.
what do you live in?
Like a small walk?
Brownstone.
that's a good move.
That's a good move up.
Sucks,
but the.
But knowing your neighbor like I.
Yeah.
I also think as an adolescent,
freak me out
as an intellectual,
as a person like yourself,
I think it's incredible important to,
to experience this.
There's an exchange of cultures and a
thought thought in New York that you
just don't get.
You don't get on the west coast.
it's also not entertainment based.
There's a frivolousness to the thought
process out here that's flavored by the
desire for fame.
Avoidable.
But the one thing I'll say is that,
yeah,
it's important for that and I find it so
energizing New York,
all the reasons you said,
but I also have to force myself to get
out of the bubble.
You know,
like
I go home to pittsburgh and I hear a lot
more oftentimes political and
intellectual diversity than I hear
sometimes in a week in New York.
Right?
Because everyone's left.
most people,
everyone in the.
Most of my friends are not everyone but
everyone.
Just conservative people in New York
obviously,
but it's certainly norman ever left
leaning,
leaning city,
Oregon.
Like it's like,
oh,
people
believe a lot of things.
You know.
My mom was the one who told me that
trump was gonna win
because she,
for her business,
we live in squirrel hill.
My family,
we went,
I was bar mitzvahed in the synagogue.
That was shot up,
so that's where we live in squirrel hill
and the jewish neighborhood,
but my mom for her work has to drive
like two or three hours out of the city
and during the campaign she would see
every.
Everyone I knew thought hillary was
gonna win,
including me,
and she called me and said,
barry,
you would not believe like the homemade
signs,
like they're giant homemade signs on
this,
on the side of people's houses and barns
that are enormous.
That took them many hours to make.
There's a passion for him that I don't
think people are fully appreciating.
Like I didn't see that everyone I knew
was voting for hillary clinton.
Right.
I don't know,
like,
I don't know what it's like for you out
here
is the same.
It's.
I mean it's incredible.
Not,
not only is it incredibly left leaning,
but is also the entertainment aspect of
it where people have to signal the fact
that they're left so they'd go out of
their way to project this image of being
progressive on top of being progressive.
It's,
it's almost critical to your job.
You know,
you have to.
you have to show everybody you can out
progressive with the people
in secret.
did they tell you what they really think
because you're like a safe person?
No,
no,
no.
Not those people to people that are
like,
man,
I don't like her,
but he's such a piece of shit I'm going
to vote for.
Anyway.
That was more common.
The thing was we like socially.
People appreciate the democrats and the
left because they feel like socially in
terms of like,
here's a perfect example.
When barack obama was the president and
you know,
people can criticize his policies and
the whistle blower or the fact that he
cracked down on whistle blowers and the
fact that there was more innocent killed
by drone strikes and they have all that
stuff is.
There's certainly some.
No one's pr.
It's an impossible job.
No one's perfect as a president,
but what he did do was he represented,
first of all,
he represented the fact that a minority
or an african american who was born from
a single mother can somehow or another
rise to be the president of the United
States and be incredibly well spoken and
measured and calm and just seems to know
how to carry himself and makes us feel
like someone better than us is in a
position of power and it also,
I feel like there was a lot of racism
from what from a horrible white people
that looked at him in a terrible way and
saw this black person trying to destroy
America,
but way more people that aren't racist
go,
huh?
Look at that.
You can't have an african american
president look at this like we're
getting better.
Like that's how I felt.
I felt like we're getting better.
Like culturally the way,
the way we communicate,
we don't have that right now and we
didn't have that with her.
What she didn't,
what she represented was the same old
thing.
The thing that's been fucking
you and the reason why your family lost
the farm and the reason why in this
donald trump's going to come in here and
he's going to clean up the swamp,
and when he came out with that drain the
swamp and lock her up,
build that wall,
he boiled it down so that the people
that don't have the time or the
inclination to really deep dive into
their own personal biases to their own
objective reasoning and find out what is
it?
Why do I think the way?
I think the people that don't have that
thought,
all that build,
that wall shit was perfect.
Line it up and that's most folks.
Most folks don't have the time.
Most folks Work all day.
They're tired.
They have a family.
they probably have a hobby.
they don't have the fucking time.
You are a person who thinks for living,
you think and write for a living.
You're constantly involved.
Well,
one thing I'm seeing when I asked you
about the people,
people telling you their secret thought
crimes,
I am noticing and in a weird way this
gives me kind of a hope.
There is a big gap between people's
public personas of the politics that
they preach and then what they really
think and what they'll say around the
kitchen table and a lot of them are
experiencing what I call,
what I think about is like second woke,
like they're seeing the poverty or the
flaws in the wilk worldview and that
there are holes with it,
but they're kind of too scared to say
that out loud because they know it'll be
a loss of friends and social capital and
everything else.
But I,
those people talk to me a lot.
Those people send me emails a lot and
oftentimes there are people with
platforms who don't want to lose their
audience and I find that somewhat
hopeful.
I find it somewhat hopeful too,
but I also got to nut nut up.
Yes,
like come out,
come on rogan.
I figured I'd say something like that
met up.
It's a good way,
but you're right that the thought
process behind nutting up is exactly
what they need to do.
Like what's more people did it.
I think you'd realize like,
wow,
we're kind of surrounded.
It's almost like,
well,
okay.
What I think about like I am never the
smartest person in any room.
I'm not brilliant.
I promise you,
you're probably smarter than us in this
room.
Know.
I don't know if jamie had to top trust
me what makes me.
The only reason I'm sitting here is that
I have like slightly more courage than
most people and that I'm willing to say
what I think to hell with pissing some
people off or losing some friends that
weren't really my friends.
Most people aren't willing to do that
actually.
Well,
what I like about your writing in a.
What I like about talking to you today
is that you represent reason and well
thought out opinions and those two
things are very rare.
Well thought out.
Opinions are way more rare in my
opinion,
than what you usually get,
which you usually get is a
conglomeration of opinions that seemed
to make sense per peripherally or
casually.
They have a veneer of logic to them and
you're like,
I'll go with that because I don't have
the time because most people don't have
the time.
Well,
going back to Israel,
I know we're probably.
Are we wrapping up?
Going back to Israel for one second.
It's become like a pillar,
right?
It's like,
okay,
if you're on the left,
I believe in
criminal justice reform,
like any number of things.
Oh,
and by the way,
Israel is bad.
Like it became one of those things that
most people don't really think about.
Right.
And like I think it's really important
to think about things issue by issue and
not just be like,
yep,
signing up for this whole slew of
policies and views on things when
actually some of those things don't go
together at all.
Well,
one thing than the woke left,
you're not allowed to do is criticize
the more repressive aspects of islam.
You're not allowed to.
You don't do it.
If you bring up anything becomes
islamophobic in even if it's homophobic
thought,
if the ideas are homophobic or if women
have to wear restrictive clothing,
all any,
any of the things that are incredibly
commonplace,
you are not allowed to criticize those
because those fall into a protected
category.
I remember when I first ran into this in
college when we were talking,
I was in a conversation with other
feminists and I definitely consider
myself a feminist about female genital
mutilation and I encountered for the
first time a species that I've come to
know well,
which is feminist,
who sorta defend female genital
mutilation on the grounds of cultural
relativism.
Who are we to judge?
And I remember just like I did not get
over the shock of that.
you shouldn't.
That is fucking terrifying.
I mean,
that is.
Look,
I'm an outspoken,
rabid critic of circumcision.
I think it's disgusting.
I think it's ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense,
but at least your dick still works.
The idea that someone tried to equate
circumcision and female genital
mutilation,
a person on the left did when I talked
about it recently,
some fucking asshole online.
I don't remember who it was,
but I didn't even.
I didn't even exchange.
I just,
I read it and I went there.
Their vagina doesn't work the same way
anymore.
Do you understand that you can't have an
orgasm anymore.
You're cutting off a woman's cliteracy
too.
Not because of cleanliness or any
fucking weird logic that they're using
today to try to justify circumcision.
Way worse,
you're.
You're doing it to try to eliminate
pleasure because you don't want the
woman to leave.
It'S the same reason why you want to
cover up with some crazy,
but why barb?
But
the leaders of the women's march talk
about say,
I don't know,
honor killings,
female genital mutilation,
forced marriage for,
for,
for girls,
children,
children.
Instead they're talking about bds in
Israel.
I don't get it.
I'd love to ask someone about that also.
Have you been to Israel?
No,
I have not.
I want to take you say yes.
I would go.
I would certainly go.
I've got to bring already though.
He'll translate.
Is that the guy?
He's a good friend.
Um,
and he loves to travel too,
so he'd be down in heartbeat.
Um,
what was I gonna say?
Oh,
why?
Why is it that,
do you think that here's,
here's a better way for them.
Do you think there's too many things to
pay attention to?
Not just worldwide,
but even in terms of like left versus
right in,
in,
in these positions,
like I often talk to people about gun
control and um,
and when people find out that I own guns
and the,
that I'm not entirely in favor of second
amendment being repealed.
One thing that drives me crazy is they
want to always bring up school
shootings,
mass shootings,
all these different things which I agree
are horrific,
terrible occurrence in our culture and
is happening in this insanely frequent
way.
And it doesn't make sense,
but people don't want to talk about is
that almost all those people are on
psych medication.
Almost all of them right now,
correlation does not equal causation.
Them being on the psych medicine might
be the same reason why they're shooting
up schools in the first place.
They're,
they're incredibly mentally unwell and
legally buy a gun.
It's insane.
That's great.
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
Not only do I think that you should then
here's the question,
who are,
who is the person to decide,
and this is the what the nra would say,
and this is what a pro second amendment
people would say.
Who are you to decide whether or not
someone is healthy enough or well enough
to own a gun and does a person who is on
antidepressants or person who has
psychological problems not have the
ability to defend themselves if they
have never exhibited violence,
so here's the problem.
A lot of these mother fuckers,
they don't exhibit violence until they
break until they pop and then they'd go
shoot up a school.
Sometimes there's threats like adam
lanza or a couple other ones were the
fbi comes and visits them and they
talked to them or the guy in Colorado
where they knew he was like hanging on
by a string,
but
he was on that gap,
which I think is like a far writer.
It's definitely used by the fire,
right?
It's used by the far right.
The problem is when you have no
restriction whatsoever and you have
restriction and all these other ones,
right?
If you say something antisemitic or
racist on twitter,
they will ban you.
If you do it on facebook,
they'll ban you and gab is committed 100
percent of free speech.
I've.
I've read things the owners of gab have
said about this and that they're.
They're very steadfast in their support
for freedom of speech because they think
what I said earlier that the best way to
ensure that good ideas get through is to
not suppress bad ideas,
but to combat them with better ideas.
I was going to say is that the guy who
shot up
the synagogue in pittsburgh was saying
the most horrific things about the cake
infestation in your country
on gab and that's.
That's where the question is,
well,
should someone like roku pull Alex
Jones?
Should they take off?
I think that this is a real question
like as someone who's to myself on the
free making the free speech argument a
lot,
I think it's something that we really,
really have to grapple with.
IT really.
It's almost like we're dealing with
crude tools,
like we're trying to perform surgery
with hatchets oh fuck man,
how do you get to those people and have
that discussion with all those people,
but this is.
I mean in terms of there being too much
to talk about and cover,
that's where I do think that things like
the New York times can make a real
contribution because we like there are
adults in the room deciding what the
important news is that you should pay
attention to in theory at least.
Well,
no,
I,
I wholeheartedly agree.
You know,
you're going to learn about the genocide
of the week muslims in the New York to
and like if you really read the New York
times every day,
you're going to know a lot about the
world and you're going to understand
that the government shut down is a
bigger deal than what happened on the
steps of the lincoln memorial.
If you're just trolling through twitter,
which is how like every person I know,
or twitter or snapchat or whatever,
like my youngest sister,
how she gets her news,
you're not going to necessarily know
that.
That's a real problem is I don't know
how to solve it other than tell people
to subscribe to newspapers,
which still have some standards and
which still when they make a mistake,
correct.
The mistake.
How many of those are left?
There's a few.
Yeah,
I work at one of them.
One of them.
You definitely do.
I mean,
look,
I.
I said something to someone from the New
York times online after a,
an article that they wrote about a
fight.
There was a boxing match economy.
Mcgregor and floyd mayweather were
congress.
It was a great fight.
Floyd made with school them,
but at the end it said that conor
mcgregor's face was swollen and bleeding
and he was knocked through the ropes and
I said,
you can't say that because everybody saw
the fight.
That didn't happen in this crazy time
where everybody is crying out for fake
news.
You can't say his face was covered in
blood when there was no blood.
You can't say that like don't do.
That was corrected.
It was corrected.
Which is so rare,
but it's actually not.
We correct things.
Yes,
all the time.
Right,
but how do you stop it from happening in
the first place?
How do you stop that one?
Well,
no,
the first one is really high blood.
No,
no blood when it doesn't exist.
I'm sorry,
what I'm saying it's really hard.
What I mean is journalists just
shouldn't make mistakes like that,
but we do the difference with the New
York times and any number of these other
places is that we say we made a mistake
and we correct.
Well,
it's high part matters pros.
It's like someone having getting ahead
of themselves having a little too much
fun.
Don't remember that article.
Well,
it wasn't necessarily think it's getting
ahead and read some fiction.
They applied fiction to an actual sport
event,
which I thought was bizarre,
but.
But they correct.
They did correct it.
Well,
here's what's important.
What's important is you can at least get
a better version of the facts there than
you can anywhere else.
Yes,
and I,
I guess there's some people in the new
media landscape that I see and I don't
know if it's because they want to sort
of join up their own audiences are what
like nihilistic getting like using
trumpist language to describe the press.
Would they don't see?
Would they don't know?
I think what they don't understand is
that the loss of trust in the press is a
symptom of the loss of trust in lots of
public institutions.
The who,
the world health organization just came
out with this terrifying report.
We're like one of the top 10 threats to
health in.
I think the country you should,
we should look this up,
is people who aren't getting vaccines.
People who think vaccines cause autism
and are not getting vaccines.
The stakes of like loss of trust in
public institutions doesn't just mean
like you're gonna like hurt the New York
times,
bottom line.
It's like a threat to all of our health.
Like quite literally,
you know,
I see these things as being very,
very connected.
So when I see people gleefully
celebrating like the fake news of the
New York times,
I'm like juva better alternative right
now,
you know?
Right.
That's what I'm thinking.
Not you,
but no.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
I don't understand why anyone would
celebrate that.
Think it falls into what we were talking
about before that it's an easily
digestible ideology that you can just
subscribe to.
It's a conglomeration of preformed
opinions and you lock in.
You start saying fake news,
and this is.
It's also,
it's exacerbated by this situation that
we find ourselves in where people aren't
really buying newspapers anymore.
You have to get people to subscribe.
I subscribe to several on my phone and
on my computer and that's how I digest
things now or an ipad.
When you,
you think about what they have to do to
get those clicks and you see these weird
look,
it is not a knock on forbes.
I think forbes is an excellent
periodical.
They're great.
They,
they,
they write some really important stuff,
but almost every month they will write
this super click baity thing about cell
phones.
Like it comes with a nasty surprise.
The new galaxy s 10 has a nasty surprise
and it's so unimaginative.
Yes.
Look,
see if you can find how many nasty
surprise articles about iphones and I've
about video games and stuff a lot too.
Did they have like a contributor network
that people are just allowed to write
articles on?
Ah,
they allow post used to have that too.
Yeah.
That fucking stuff is so dangerous
because as soon as people lose trust
that you are unbiased and you're giving
them an objective perspective on exactly
what's going on,
as soon as that mean,
it might be nothing when it comes to
galaxy s tens or whatever the fuck
they're talking about.
This has a nasty surprise,
but.
But it,
it flavors your perspective on news of
course.
And these people are fighting for their
life.
Journalists and people in contributors
to these websites and news and
newspapers are fighting for their life
because everything is dropping off.
The revenues are down,
the revenues are.
And then like what's what takes their
place?
What took place?
Bloggers,
who's,
who's looking at them?
Are you sure that they have journalistic
ethics and standards that are like what
we would expect from?
They don't.
They know,
right?
They don't have to.
And this brings you to the end from ars
info wars thing,
right?
He,
if he's a journalist,
he's definitely not a journalist,
but this is,
but this is what people are fighting
about.
This is.
This is the whole shebang.
Like if,
if some of that news that you're getting
in these traditional venues is fake,
it is dangerous.
If any of it is click baity.
If any of it is deceptive and agree with
you more,
it's fucking dangerous.
Especially because we have a president
who attacks the presses,
the member like clinton.
I forget the context we're operating.
Yes.
You know,
we have trump calling us the enemy of
the people so crazy.
The lack of understanding of views it
insane.
Yeah,
for sure.
There were easy to drive insane though.
let's be honest.
There's a lot of dummies out there
that's part of the problem.
It's just,
it's so easy to prod a certain group and
they're like,
I'm done.
I'm going to do something about this.
This is,
this is the danger,
this is what you have to worry about.
The people that they,
and again,
they're signaling to their signaling to
the far right,
they're signaling to those people.
I know a lot of people like that.
Not that would shoot people,
but I know a lot of people that are
signalers that like far right signaler,
so like they'll see things and I've.
I've talked to people that I hope trump
wins because we've got to put a stop to
all this nonsense with the nonsense.
It's progressive nonsense.
The idea socialist like bernie sanders
going to come along and take all your
money.
We're struggling hard working americans.
We've got to put America first.
Put America first.
It's just lack of understanding about
the complexity of the entire landscape,
the entire landscape in terms of
economics,
entire landscape in terms of
international politics,
all of it.
All the above the war machine into the,
the,
the lack of understanding about the
military industrial complex and the
influence that it has.
The lack of understanding about the
bankers,
about how few people went to jail after
the fucking crazy economic collapse that
we just recovered.
From what I mean,
if you view,
you've seen inside job,
you seen that documentary.
It's an amazing documentary,
but it's all about the financial
collapse.
Pulled that up,
find out,
uh,
I watched it.
It's from 2000,
I want to say 10:11.
But it's so sobering
when you have this guy who's an
economics of real,
true economics expert questioning these
people who in many cases they're a
economics professors at major
universities who give advice.
Okay.
Two thousand 10.
I was right.
Charles ferguson.
That was a gentleman.
He did a good job.
I know.
It's so sad.
He's a good guy.
I met him,
but he's forever.
Team America is one of the greatest
movies of all time.
That ideology should roll.
Yes.
Yeah.
And you know what I love about it more
than anything,
the whole idea that actors have to save
the world
because I just think is so brilliant
that I inadvertently saw that movie with
my dad and my grandfather and I will
never forget the puppet sex scene
watching that
today.
That oh,
rIght next to your desk and you know you
should they ever make that movie.
Do you know what I made a mistake of
doing yesterday?
I watch ace ventura pet detective with
my eight year old and my 10 year old
since they came out with a good still.
I didn't realize how transphobic that
fucking movie is
alert.
The whole premise is that there was an
ace ventura pet detective.
I got a spoiler it myself because I
forgot the Whole premise was wet.
This guy steals a dolphin and when he
steals a dolphin,
ace ventura fines because he's a pet
detective,
finds a tiny ruby that's at the bottom
of this dolphin tank that is missing
from a miami dolphins ring.
And he finds out through this exhaustive
search that the one guy who he couldn't
account for his ring was a kicker who
fucked up the world series or the
superbowl rather.
So this suit,
this guy,
this guy that they found out is Sean
Young in the movie who's gorgeous.
And then in the movie can take that down
please.
So in the movie at the end of it,
the reveal is that Sean Young is really
this football player who wants to get
back at dan marino because dan murray,
he's Go psycho because the world hates
him because he blew the kick.
So he's a guy pretending to be a woman
and ace ventura made out with them.
And just like everyone saw the cops are
throwing up.
Everyone's throwing up on or off.
it's off the charts.
At the end he pulls her top off and
shows and she has breasts.
He was like trying to show that she
didn't really abreast and she did.
and he's like,
well,
anybody can get those and an afternoon,
but what about this?
And he pulls her pants down and then he
goes by and then everybody sees her and
she's got her legs together so you can't
see your penis.
And then from behind you see her junk is
pressed up against her butt cheeks
because she's tucked her penis and her
vagina.
So the cops all start throwing up.
And then cops started cleaning cops that
made out with her and start cleaning
their mouth off.
They start chewing giant wad there.
That's her scene.
So watch all the cops see that.
And he points to the fact that sean,
you look,
they all start throwing up.
Look,
everyone's throwing up.
This is dan marino's throwing up.
See how he's cleaning his mouth because
he,
he made out with her tone loke the
dolphins freaking out.
Everyone's freaking out.
It is so insanely transformed.
So what the left would say is the reason
that they're right is that a movie like
this won't get made anymore.
And isn't that a good thing?
Maybe should they pull it?
Shouldn't.
Should it be illegal to have that on
itunes?
Of course not.
Oh,
maybe someone on the left might disagree
with you right now.
You transphobic for defending this
horrible cisgendered heteronormative
shit movie that's horrible.
And what's crazy,
and I guess this is a great thing.
I mean the remodelization project is
working because when I saw that,
I'm sure is.
I don't know.
What year did that come out?
90 five for.
Okay.
So when I saw that as a,
I don't know,
I was born in 84.
I can't do math.
I want to say [inaudible] 93.
I want to say it was before I came to
hollywood.
When I saw that movie I was 10.
Transphobia was not a thing.
No,
no,
it is the thing.
That's good.
Well that's good about when things are
changing so rapidly,
but the question is where are the lines
being drawn and is the overton window
being shrunk too small?
How do you feel about them pulling the
dukes of hazzard off the air for the
flag?
I don't know about that.
You didn't know about that?
No,
they pulled the dukes of hazard.
You understand?
Do you understand how many of these
there are so many.
Yeah,
so no,
I don't know that one.
What's that one?
This one.
They yanked the dukes of hazzard off
television forever because the
confederate flag was on the roof of the
generally did not follow this.
Didn't know that.
You cannot watch the news a hazard
anymore.
You cannot watch it.
It's not on television anymore.
It used to be on tv land all the time.
Can you just get it?
Fuck no,
no chance.
They're not going to show that god damn
awful flag.
We have a poster in the bathroom over
there of leonard skinner from like 1970
something and they have a giant janis
joplin.
I thought in the bathroom.
The other bathroom.
Who?
Janis joplin.
Oh,
That's the other bathroom.
Yeah,
there's different like.
that's great one.
That's her mug shot.
I love it.
Yeah,
that's right.
Um,
but the,
the leonard scared one,
they have a giant confederate flag on
stage.
Huge.
Enormous in the background that was
there like southern pride,
this idea of southern pride.
It was okay to have that flag.
I'm basically for trying to,
when it comes to the realm of art and
movies and books,
leave it alone.
Try to leave It alone as much as
possible.
It's generally a very good strategy.
I agree.
I don't want to be in the book banning
movie banning tv,
banning business or editing.
They tried to mobile.
They,
I think they did successfully at least
in some venues,
edit a tom sawyer and huck finn because
the n word was used prolifically,
you know?
I mean the guy's name was nigger jim.
That was the name in the book because
that's how people talk back then and I
think we need to keep that stuff as a
time capsule to show how racism.
Yes,
yes.
It's important to show the progress like
ace ventura,
like,
like for trans people,
keep him for history for trans people
and it's amazing that no one's ever
brought this up.
I mean,
I feel like this is something that's
never been discussed from you.
Joe rogan about the implant.
I got shit to do.
I got,
I got jokes.
Right,
but this is.
You got an Israel trip that I'm planning
and are,
what are you doing to me,
mary,
you're not dragging.
You want to take you on an amazing trip
and then we're going to go to the west
bank and you're gonna see all this stuff
and you're going to come away with
loving certain parts of it and not
liking certain parts of it and you're
going to realize it's a country just
like any other country,
but it is a democracy and it's trying to
do what's best in a really rough
neighborhood and we'll go like,
I want you to see what the occupation
looks like.
Like I think that's something that's
really important to see to get a full
picture of it.
I think you're probably right.
I think it is an important thing for
people to see.
Um,
I think there's a lot of parts of the
world that I need to see to really get a
grasp.
Where do you want to go?
Where you going next in the world?
You travel a lot.
Yes.
I don't know.
I mean,
my family and I,
we do a european vacation trip,
but that doesn't really count.
We just lounge.
It's just fun.
I went to Thailand last year.
That was fascinating.
Cool.
Thailand was fascinating because that
was kind of a vacation trip too,
but that's such a uniQue culture because
Thailand is run by the king or even
criticize the king.
You're,
you're fucked.
Like you're in real trouble.
And his is everywhere.
Everywhere.
There's pictures of him in the throne
like wearing like super nice clothes and
look good,
but the people are so kind.
they're so friendly and they're always
smiling and they have,
you know,
there's a lot of people that you'll run
into that have very little yet.
They don't seem to be having a problem
with that.
They wear flip flops.
You're on the highway.
There's three people on a motorcycle is
a baby in a basket and I'm not
bullshitting.
No helmet.
and then friend that just went to
Thailand,
but the people are so nice.
They're so nice.
They're so kind.
It's so unusual.
And you know,
me and my famIly,
we had.
We always,
whenever we go somewhere,
we always have this real long
conversations about like what was
interesting about it for you?
Like what,
what did you think,
like your kids?
Eight and 10,
the young ones and I have a 22 year old
to all girls holla and from for girls
blue jeans,
but the,
the,
what's fascinating to me about it is,
well first of all I love exposing these
little people to different parts of the
world so they get to see like what this
is like,
you know,
like here we are,
show them on the map.
This is America,
we're over here.
but when the fucking 15 hours to get
here a plane that goes 500 plus miles an
hour,
it's crazy.
And just to realize like human beings
are the same but different.
We're the same everywhere,
but there's a different way.
We choose to interact with each other
and one of the things that happens is we
fall into their way.
When we go there.
Like if we go to Italy,
we say razzi,
I try to,
you try to start learning.
We'll just start trying to learn.
Some of the worDs that people use in
their culture and then,
oh,
I forgot how you say it,
cups,
zoom crop.
I think that's how you said it's like
hello and good morning and but they all
say that and eveRyone makes a lotus
flower with their hands.
It's so common.
Everywhere you go,
people greet you and they do thIs and
it's such a warm,
friendly,
peaceful way of greeting each other.
And so one of the things that we talked
about it,
I was like,
you know,
everybody's like way more friendly and
like greeting and this thing about
clapping their hands together and they
all agree to do it and everyone can sort
of.
It's like this unique pattern that
people can fall into and people fall
into all sorts of patterns.
They fall into like really aggressive
patterns of honking at people on the
road and driving real fast and then they
fall into these peaceful patterns and
some of it's dictated by culture.
Some of It's dictated by climate.
Some of it is dictated by the economic
situation in the world they're in,
but it's such a weird trip to go to
different places and see like,
okay,
yeah,
if I lived over here,
this is how I'd rocket,
I'd be wearing flip flops and shorts and
I'd get around this way and this is the
kind of food that I would eat.
And real spicy because you know,
you kind of have to have those spices
actually protect against bacteria
because they're there.
They're actually antIbacterial.
Was the food grade fucking amazing.
We took some court,
we took classes,
we learned how to cook over there.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
It was amazing.
But my kid got lit up by bugs.
Whew.
There's a thing called tsetse flies.
I think that's what they're called.
I forget what they're called,
but my youngest had a horrible allergic
reaction to some of the bugs over there
get.
And you know,
you think like,
okay,
like,
what about,
uh,
you know,
there's,
there's fucking diseases that kill
people.
Malaria kills.
Malaria has killed more people than
anything ever.
Like more people have died from malaria
than anything.
Oh,
I know.
Yeah,
well that's why gates made its.
totally.
Yeah,
and so you go over there like we were
going to go to africa is one of the
things that we're going to go to,
But I'm not giving my fucking eight year
old malaria shots.
Just know just like it's health,
getting really bad dreams.
I've had some friends that dave foley
who was like the sweetest guy on the
planet earth.
He was from kids in the hall,
was on news radio with me.
Dave foley was on malaria medication
because he was going to visit his kids
in Egypt so we have to take this stuff
and he was drinking,
you're not supposed to drink on it.
And
he.
He was just going crazy.
He doesn't even remember it.
He was going crazy.
Taking reporters a microphone or as a
tape recorder away and put it in a
drink.
It was like losing his marbles.
Like I had to protect him yelling at a
guy like crowd.
I'm like calm down.
Meanwhile the sweetest,
kindest,
nicest guy you would ever meet.
And meanwhile he was like super aggro,
was crazy.
It didn't make any sense.
And it's the medication.
He just had a horrible reaction.
I have other friends that had just like
horrific waking up,
soaked in sweat,
evil,
nightmares,
demons chasing them like fuck this
medication.
This is too much man.
But.
But my point is,
yeah,
I'd be down to go to Israel.
I'd be good.
I think I need to go to open to that
part of the world.
No,
I want to go to giza too.
That's the other place I really need to
go to.
I've been obsessed with the pyramid
since I was a little kid.
Can be one trip.
All right,
I'm on it.
done.
Let's do it.
And you can set up a debate for me and
I'm in for that to
go.
No,
no.
Go pee.
I don't know if I'm setting up a few
debates.
I don't know if I can set that one up.
That one seems problematic.
No,
she's hilarious.
She's going to drag me to Israel.
She's a powerful lady though,
right?
Scott?
She's got some,
some horsepower behind our opinions.
Are you going to come with us?
Got it.
You got to take pictures,
man.
You're a professional photographer at
this camera for.
Yeah.
Um,
would you feel nervous?
Where would you feel more nervous going
to giza are going to gaza.
Gaza,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
shit could pop off at any minute.
You just don't want to be there when it
all goes sour.
Yeah.
A friend of my dad in the eighties,
he was a,
he was on this weird belief to beirut
and he was being tracked.
He found out once he got back,
he met ronald reagan when he met
president reagan.
He said,
it's nice to meet you.
We've been following you.
And he's like,
excuse,
excuse me,
good following me.
So yeah,
we found out there was like a threat
like after you take,
but I think he fainted on the spot or
something like that.
There was a threat.
Yeah.
You're just going to deliver a hot dog.
His name is hot dog hair.
He was trying to help the troops and
stuff.
And what was the threat?
They were trying to kill them.
Jesus delivered hot dog at one point,
uh,
a car pull up next to him.
And I guy with a gun,
how to like rep to his head and that the
cab got the cab driver.
Thankfully.
No,
it was happening like took off and he
didn't die.
Why would they were gonna kill him just
for delivering high.
Don't remember the exact situation.
Like they weren't happy.
He was over there trying to help someone
do shit.
Yeah,
I believe that's how it went down.
Yeah.
Fuck
yeah.
There's spots in the world that are just
so fucked up.
Like you don't want to go because you,
you,
you hear and you're like,
I don't want to get caught up in that.
I don't want to get caught up in that
one.
I could just stay burbank.
Why would I go and get caught up in
that?
But then there's other parts.
He goes,
man,
for your own edification,
you should probably go just to
understand what it's like.
Did you hear about those ladies that
were killed in Morocco?
Hey,
you're back.
Um,
you shut that door.
That's okay.
We're just talking about going to
dangerous places and it's probably a
good idea.
But you get scared and you know for the
most part you probably shouldn't be
scared,
but sometimes you should.
And we were just talking about those
women that were killed in Morocco,
those norwegian hikers,
they were from where they're from,
Norway or Denmark,
I forget.
They were there hiking and morocco's to
women and they were killed by these.
But one was just kidding Australia,
20 year old israeli good.
The one that killed people that were
doing it because of the United States
involvement in Syria and they cut their
heads off and phone camera and they put
it on the internet and I watched it.
You watched it.
So why would you watch that?
You don't want it.
Because I was reading the story and the
video was there and I just clicked it
and I shouldn't have.
And just to see it.
It's just part of me wants to know that
people like that exist.
They exist.
I know they exist,
but I don't want it to be an abstract.
You know what?
I watched the danny pearl video.
I've never watched another video like
that again.
Yeah,
I saw that one too.
I've seen quite a few of them now you
need to know,
I don't want to go there,
you know,
I mean,
it's not worth it to go to a place where
that's happening,
but you need to know that that's
happening,
right?
In order to have a realistic perspective
on world events,
you need to know what it is at the worst
end of the spectrum.
Like what is,
what is the,
what are the consequences for rabbit
ideologies?
well,
I've thought about that with like what
we decide to show and not show after
mass shootings here,
you know,
like
um,
I was in pittsburgh like right after and
I was because I knew the rabbi who was
doing some of the cleanup and
because of religious reasons and that
you were,
you,
your bat mitzvah was there.
That is sO crazy.
Yeah.
My dad knew six of the people who were
murdered and um,
but like,
it was really crazy to me how locked
down.
It wasn't like you couldn't take it.
I was there with a photographer and you
couldn't take any pictures at all of
anything,
you know?
And there's a real lockdown on showing
people Because you don't want to terrIfy
people,
but I've wondered would it prick
people's consciousness about the reality
of what gun violence looks like?
You know,
like the carnage,
like the people that I know that saad
said it looked like a war zone and would
that change public policy and would that
be a posItive thing or would we just
become numb to it?
Like we become numb to everything else?
No,
no,
it's a very good question.
I,
I'm never in favor of suppressing
inflammation.
even horrific information.
Um,
I was a big critic of that during the
bush administration when they passed
laws on whether or not you're allowed to
show actual coffins,
just coffins.
You weren't allowed to show coffIns
being flown back.
I felt like that was,
that's a disgrace.
That's,
I mean,
you should,
if you,
if,
if we're going to consider whether or
not we want to go to war,
we should be able to understand the real
consequences.
And one of the best ways is to not just
get information in terms of text.
Text is very difficult for you to
conceptualize,
but when you would,
seeing american flags covering coffins,
when you're seeing hundreds of them and
you realize these are your neighbors,
these are your neighbors children's,
this is,
this is people that you,
you know,
and they're dyIng over there and you
can't really.
You can't wrap your head around why
they're doing it and whether or not it's
right,
whether or not we should have been there
and then whether or not they're actually
were weapons of mass destruction in
Iraq,
whether or not we're in the business of
nation building,
whether or not ron paul is right,
whether or not other people are right.
Well who's right,
like the only way we're really going to
get a clear picture is to see a picture.
To have an actual
picture.
Yeah.
Well that's why I've thought about this
a lot because rIght now I think in most
american's minds it's like the shooting
happens.
Then it becomes a hashtag,
then it becomes a tee shirt.
Then it becomes a memorial thing,
a memorial concert.
I mean it's like actually sickening like
the the choreography of it and I think
what's lost is what it looks like and
this rabbi in pittsburgh who is really
amazing,
describe to me what he saw and I'll
never forget just the description of
what he told me and I wondered.
I've wondered a lot in the wake of that
and I'll think about it with the next
shooting happens.
Would that have made a difference at all
in terms of waking people up?
What's fucked up as you said,
when the shooting happens,
that's what's fucked when we know it
will happen.
We know a lot,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Why?
Because because there are a lot of guns
in this country and people have access
to those guns who are not only mentally
unwell.
Sometimes they're just evil and they
want to kill people and they want to be
famous.
I mean for a million reasons,
but the fact that we're living in a
culture that seems to worship people's
freedom to own those weapons more than
human life seems crazy to me.
It really does.
I get what you're saying.
The argument against that would be this,
look,
the real crazies believed that these
things are happening and that they're
happening because of the fact that
government wants to take away our guns.
This is the real crazies.
Explain that.
I'm not sure I followed that.
They are making these people do these
things.
The government that the worst worst
aspects of our society,
whatever,
fill the blank with whatever left wing
conspiracy that you know,
whatever person,
whatever,
boogeyman,
george soros,
whatever the fuck the boogie man is that
the whatever boogeyman or book or cabal
of boogie people that they are somehow
or another either using like manchurian
candidate type influence,
whatever the fuck they're doing,
they're getting people to do this and
then even creating false flags where
these things didn't happen so they can
take away guns.
This is the.
I mean this is exactly what
it is.
You're right.
It is.
It is dumb,
but it's real.
It's real.
In terms of the influence that it has,
that people actually do believe that
there are these false flag events that
they're designing to to get your guns,
that people are training people to go
out and kill a bunch of people so that
they can take away your guns,
so it makes them more rabid about their
support of the second amendment and
they,
they feel like they're being attacked on
all sides.
have you looked very recently?
Last week?
The mindset of the conspiracy thinker is
totally fascinating to me.
It is.
A midwest is actually just as good or
even better.
he runs medibank.
He's a fascinating guy.
I used to do the show.
I did the show for awhile on scifi.
I called joe Rogan questions everything,
and one of the things that we went into
was a why people believe in chem trails,
why people believe that the heat of jet
engines,
which causes these artificial clouds
when it interacts with condensation,
the atmosphere and creates,
you know,
creates artificial clouds.
You see called trails.
Some people believe that these are,
that someone's spraying something and
that this weather control from these
commercial jets that they're somehow
though is this gigantic conspiracy of
all these people involved and that this
is in some way,
uh,
they're,
they're either doing weather control or
they're controlling us or mind control.
It depends on who you ask.
And that may kind of really interesting
way of discussing it.
And one of the things that he said is
this is like the training wheels for
conspiracy theory because you see it in
the sky.
Let's look.
There it is.
I don't remember that anymore.
There's photographs from world war ii
where you can see from the 19 forties,
you could see contrails in the sky that
looked just like the ones up here,
but people will say,
I don't remember those when we were kids
people.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I don't.
And then it starts fueling this paranoid
idea that there's this program going on.
And then there are real programs that
the government is CoNsideriNg to combat
global warming.
Where they talked about thIs in the,
in the seventies and the eighties.
They talked about reflective particles
in the atmosphere.
I think they were when they were
concerned that the ozone layer was meant
mammals the eighties probably probably
later than that,
but even more recently they've talked
about suspending reflective particles in
the atmosphere to protect it,
but it'd be very differeNt,
but why do people believe conspiracy
theories?
what is it in the nature of certain
people that when I'm just so fascinated
bY it.
That's a good question.
That's what I was going to ask you.
What do you.
When you see it from the outside,
when you see something like a,
like The most horrific ones,
like sandy hook,
sandy hook being a false flag,
what would be the motivation for someone
saying that?
What would be the Motivation?
The only thing I can.
I mean the most plausible I guess would
be
capturing an audience,
like getting people to believe in you is
some sier behind the veil.
Yeah,
but that's only the people that are
projecting this in terms of the media.
Alex jones,
like why does he say that was my
question is why do other people think
it?
Why do they look for it?
Not,
not a person?
No,
I think that's.
I think the reason people look to
conspiracy theories is that the world is
deeply chaotic and seems to lack a logic
and people are desperate for a system of
understanding the world and conspiracy
theories often seem to like offer a
very,
very actually like an incredibly
simplistic explanation,
which is there's this secret fit.
Like if there's always a secret thing
that is a plan that the public doesn't
know about.
General mills.
The thing is that no one really is at
the wheel.
Yeah.
The real thing is that,
I mean,
haven't we learned that from the trump
presidency?
Right.
Like institutions are just made up with
people like they can fall apart if the
people that take them over are
irresponsible,
crazy,
venal,
narcissistic.
Everything that we're seeing in the
trump administration will also like
people.
But isn't that kind of.
It's weirdly.
I mean it's both terrifying,
but also comforting.
I think like if it's people,
if it's just people,
people can also change it.
It's not like there's a secret hand that
we need to get to just,
okay,
what's the solution?
Elect better people.
That's the hopeful part.
We think that this such as it is,
this constant conflict,
this social conflict that we're involved
in right now,
the woke left and the outright and all
this jazz,
that there's the boiling of it right now
will eventually boiled down to something
more rational because if it seems like
if you.
If you read steven pinker's work and
people that study violence and in danger
and society over the course of history
that we're.
We're certainly on an upward trend.
Even though data shows us all the data
shows that no one's denying that there
are some awful aspects to our culture
today in society and crime and violence
and fill in the blank disparity and yes,
all those things exist,
but there's more understanding of that
is more awareness of that and there's
certainly a safer,
safer world today than was 100,
200 years ago.
In terms of like your own.
Well,
just think about my life like I am a
woman who can walk down the street of
almost any american city with all the
privileges that I have granted,
but unharmed.
Yes.
That's a miracle in human history.
It is.
Like there's one day I was at the beach
and I was like,
wow,
I'm just sitting here in a bathing suit.
No one's coming up to me.
No one's harassing me.
How many parts of the world could I do
that in?
you know,
like I,
I try and keep that in mind when I'm
falling into despair about where we are
as a country where I'm like,
oh,
actually in a lot of ways it's still
like the best thing of the worst things.
It's the best thing in history so far.
It's certainly for women,
so I try and kind of keep that in mind
when I'm losing myself to feelings,
to fears that things are going to get
worse before they get better,
which is what I think.
I,
I have
all daughters and I have friends that
are women and I have a lot of friends
that are women in the world of standup
comedy and
I oftentimes see misogynist shit online
that shocks me and one of the things
that shocked me was there's a guy that I
follow and he was talking about how his
wife a thread on twitter,
well thought out,
very smart guy.
He's a lawyer and I was talking about
how his wife's gas tank is always empty,
so every time he gets into his wife's
car,
she's always out of gas.
I was like,
what the fuck?
Why do I always have to get gas for you?
And then she explained she doesn't to
park to get gas because she gets
harassed and it creeps her out and it
was like a man will never think about
that.
Not only men never think about that.
The messages he was getting from men
calling him a cock making excuse.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
there is
I,
I mean I,
I'm an idiot that I didn't think darkly
enough because of course it was going to
go there.
Right.
and he told me direct messages getting
directly,
it's just people saying all kinds of
crazy shit to him because they not only
are they in denial that this could be a
situation where their mother was in or
their wife or their daughter.
Maybe they don't have a daughter.
Maybe they have a bad relationship with
her mother.
Maybe they just,
they've had so many bat,
you know,
if a guy has had so many bad
interactions with women and he's not
very smart and he's just decided that
women are evil and you see anything
that's like saying,
hey guys,
maybe we should look at it in terms of
like how the woman looks at it.
Fuck you.
Like that's real.
Those guys are real and they're out
there.
I was at a gas station the other night
at 2:00 in the morning.
I was coming home from the comedy store
and I pulled into this gas station and
there was this guy,
yeah,
that bulletproof thing where this thick
glass,
the guy's talking to.
I'm using my credit card and this guy's
trying to use his debit card and I pull
in.
I get out of my car and I hear yelling
and I hear him going,
hey bro,
relax.
You're not a fucking bank teller.
A right.
He goes,
you're taking this job so seriously.
You make $10 an hour and the guy says
something,
there's no money on the cars.
Like fuck you.
there's $800 on this card.
And his friend from the car saying
something,
he's an I am nervous.
Okay,
I'm there.
Yes,
it's 2:00 in the morning and I'm nervous
and I'm like fuck.
And I'm like,
what if this guy turns any of this
aggression on me?
What if he decides?
I mean he's a fucking asshole and he's
probably drunk or high or something and
it's 2:00 in the morning and it's him
and there's another guy in the car and
I'm so nervous humiliating the guy who
works.
Yes,
yes.
And I'm so nervous that I'm thinking of
cutting my pump short.
I'm thinking I just don't get a full
tank.
Just get five bucks and get the fuck
outta here.
You know,
don't run out of gas,
but let's just get the fuck out here.
We'll get the gas tomorrow during the
daylight and I'm a man and I'm looking
at these two guys and I'm saying,
okay,
if some shit goes down,
if these guys don't have a weapon,
I'm gonna.
Beat the fuck out of these two guys.
Did they look skinny?
They look like they don't exercise,
but they're aggressive.
They're angry,
they're stupid.
I'm like,
god damn it.
Like all my spidey senses are going to
get out of here.
Go get out of here and like an asshole.
I decided to stay and pump my gas,
but when the the these guys are yelling
at each other.
I literally went around the front of the
car instead of the back way because it
was a shorter path for me being exposed
to their view.
So I'm hiding behind my Truck while I'm
filling my tank and I'm a man who could
kill these two guys.
I honestly thought where this story was
going to go is that you were going to go
over and tell them to stop.
I was thinking of going over there,
but I didn't want to get shot and I'm
thinking,
what if this,
some people die now I'm saying no,
but also where you can get hit in the
head with a pipe thing that you have to
worry that you're going to get shot at.
Again,
it is.
It is,
but it's not just shot.
It's just violence in general and I'm
and I'm a martial arts expert so I'm
less worried than most men and certainly
way less worried than a woman.
If I was a woman and I pulled up and I
heard that guy go,
fuck you make $10 an hour,
bro.
Fucking relaxed.
I'd be like,
oh,
get me the fuck out of here.
I was on fumes though.
Raising two daughters made you so much
more aware of this stuff?
A hundred percent.
Yeah,
and also just raising babies.
Even if there were boys,
I realized that people were babies.
Now I used to think of people as being
in a static state.
How old are you?
Thirty four.
I meet you.
I go,
oh,
34 year old person.
this is a 34 year old person.
I didn't meet you in think in the past I
would have met you and only thought of
you as a 34 year old person.
Now I look at everyone as a baby.
That's how I process things and it made
me way more compassionate,
way more understanding and way more
patient with people because I now I say,
okay,
when I meet this asshole at the gas
station to clock in the morning,
that's berating that guy.
Well,
why is he will?
Because his dad's a fucking piece of
shiT.
his life probably sucks.
He's probably dumb.
He's probably been on drugs since he was
young.
He doesn't have any smart friends.
They don't have any money to get gas at
2:00 in the morning.
They're making poor life choices.
There's a lot wrong here.
He doesn't enemy discipline in his life.
He's never gone through any sort of
trials and tribulations that taught him
about things he doesn't,
doesn't or didn't receive life lessons.
Probably didn't get a good education.
Here we are and I might have to kick
this guy's ass because it's 2:00 in the
morning and he's threatening.
He's loud and he's probably going To be
allowed to.
Other people look at them the wrong way.
He's just fucking toxically stupid,
but it was a baby.
He was a baby at one point in time,
so I don't want to go over there.
I don't want to.
I don't.
I don't want to create violence.
I'm thinking he's just going to drive
away and eventually he did and that poor
guy who probably is probably making just
a little bit more than $10 an hour is
stuck in this fucking cubicle.
This little glass box with this asshole
berating him at 2:00 in the morning,
but that's a baby that I was a baby.
My,
my,
my except not acceptance,
but my curiosity was socialism.
My real curiosity with any socialist
ideas is how do we recognize the fact
that some people are dealt the shittiest
of shitty hand of cards and that there's
entire sections of cities where everyone
has a shit hand of cards and some some
make it out through basketball and
football and sports and rap music and
whatever,
but that whole spot sucks.
The whole spot sucks.
The aberrations,
the few that make it out.
That's not indicative of that.
This is a good place and these people
just need to pull themselves up by the
bootstraps is that some salmon make it
up.
This crazy waterfall and the grizzly
bears don't eat them.
It doesn't mean that the waterfall is
save for salmon and the salmon to get
bitter bunch of pussies.
It's,
it's this,
this is chaos.
This the fact that we don't address that
and that our civilization just plows on
with the same stupid path that we've had
for decades.
Regardless of the fact that we have an
absolute understanding of the complete
inequality of the.
The real ghettos of our country.
Whether it's the south side of chicago
or whether it's baltimore or wherever it
is,
we have a real understanding of this.
This isn't,
this isn't guesswork.
We really know and we don't do a goddamn
thing about it.
That's what makes me want to embrace
some aspects of socialism.
The fact that I know it's not fair,
it's not fair.
Look,
I didn't have a Great childhood,
but it wasn't bad.
I got through.
I'm fine.
No,
he shot me.
Nobody raped me.
I got through like it could have been
way worse and it is way worse for many,
many people.
So all these pull yourself up by your
booTstraps,
assholes.
The other thing I noticed about them is
they're rarely really successful.
Like they are rare.
They really rarely are these pull
yourself up by your bootstraps people.
People who have accomplished anything
extraordinary.
It's just like an idea.
It's like it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a simplistic ideology that they've
subscribed to.
You should have aoc on.
I would love to.
We.
Her and I have gone back and on twitter.
Yeah.
That
would be really interesting to listen to
us.
She's so young.
I'm so interested in,
yeah,
she's 28 years old.
I mean,
that's amazing.
The whole thing is amazing.
She's just fascinating.
You should haVe her own.
How about when she was getting a hard
time because they found a video like
they thought they were going to get her
college dancing.
Yeah,
but you know what?
Everyone loved that video,
right?
The whole narrative that like some
random person on tWitter put that video
out.
right,
and the point is they did it because
they thought they were going to shame
her.
TheY're idiots,
but how funny is that?
They thought it was the most charming
thing in the entire world.
Anyone who did not love her already fell
in love with you.
That's what it accomplished.
And then her response to that was her
doing a little dance.
She's a genius.
She's a social media genius.
The question is,
does she do her ideas?
Stand up at all will be interesting to
hear.
Ideas can evolve,
but what she has,
it's unique and she's real and she seems
to be a really good person.
She seems to be a good person.
Now whether or not I agree with her tax
policy,
I'm not an economist.
I'm a fucking moron.
Okay?
I don't know anything about economics.
I really don't.
I mean,
you should have her almost like now
rather have her on per just.
I just want to know about her as a
person.
For my.
My thoughts on politicians is you can
hire an economist.
You could listen to them.
You could talk to them.
What we really need is people that have
the right idea as far as we're human
should go the way we should behave,
the way we should treat each other.
This,
this overwhelming need for community
that we all share.
We have to.
We have to pull this thing together and
we have to be.
We have to look at each other as a
community and that's lacking and the
people that are polarizing both on the
left and the right want,
they don't want to look at it that way.
Don't they want to look at people and
say,
hey,
you will never get better like that 16
year old kid.
No need to ever forgive him.
This kind of crazy talk,
whether it's from the right or from the
left,
is what we really need to stomp out.
We need to stop,
we need to be nicer to each other.
We need to figure out where we don't
have time.
We're not going to live long.
If you're 50 years old and this is your
idea of the world,
like,
fuck man,
you're halfway done and you're an.
You're an idiot.
You're looking at shit completely wrong
and you're halfway done with this trip.
If everything goes perfect.
I know we're like in an antireligious
period of the world's history,
but like ideas like grace and mercy.
Yeah.
Would,
would,
would go a long way in the culture right
now.
Yes.
No,
I agree.
And even even if it's just.
Even if it's really wacky,
you know,
mindfulness and yoga,
even if it's like comes from a sort of
fake guru we place in the beginning,
which a lot of times it does.
It's just people have.
I mean,
people have deep
the religious impulses and that needs to
go somewhere and so it's going to
politics and doctrinaire politics or
it's going to willfulness or it's going
to self care and wellness.
I mean,
all these things are
astrology.
It's like making a comeback isn't
really.
Yeah.
Every.
Are you kidding?
Yes.
Right?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
What's trOubling signs like?
I mean it's like all religious expert
like that energy inside of us I think is
deeply human and goat needs to go
somewhere are really smart guy who told
me it doesn't do anything until he
contacts his astrologer.
Everyone in la has one.
Yeah.
No,
that's not true.
Jamie.
Jamie does not have one.
No.
Jamie consults the weed leaves.
Yeah.
I don't know what that's about,
but I do think that people do have thiS
desire for a space daddy,
a higher power of someone that knows
something that knows more than you.
Some grand pattern to follow.
That leads to harmony.
I mean,
I tHink everybody sort of has that thing
because again,
what we're talking about before,
we do realize if we are being honeSt
that no one's at the wheel,
that we wake up,
we're almost like we're in a spaceship
and we wake up and you know,
we were in Hyper sleep and this thing
has been flying for millions of years
and we're like,
who the fuck is flying this?
Do we know who's flying?
Are you,
you're not flying.
I'm not flying them.
Well,
I'm going to,
we're going to get together and with a
form of group that flies it like,
okay,
but it still moves.
It's still moving while we're trying to
figure out who flies it and there's no
way to slow it down.
There's no breaks in this thing.
We,
we are in an organic spaceship,
we are,
and we're flying through infinity.
We're spinning a thousand miles an hour
and we're going through space and that's
real and you're going to die.
That's all those things are real.
All those things sort of make everything
else sort of pale in comparison.
The reality of that is so Bizarre and
while while we're avoiding those
thoughts were concentrating on these
very minor differences that we have that
are really framed by our teams.
You know the team,
this team says,
you gotta do this,
this team says you got to do that.
I can tell almost to a.
If you tell me you're pro life,
I go,
you vote republican.
Feel everything else about that person.
That's crazy.
The idea also that you know that you're
going to die and yet there are people
who are spending their lives hurling
pixels at other people and pixels like
on twitter.
hilarious though.
Pixels.
I never thought about it that way.
That's crazy.
This is your one life.
Yup.
That's how you want to spend it.
being mean.
Go outside.
Seriously,
like go outside,
but it's so intoxicating and it's so
new.
That's also the problem with social
media and phones in a world in which
people live alone and stare down at
their flashy screen and worship it like
a god.
This,
these networks gives you,
give you a sense of belonging and
community.
Yes,
and it also gives you something to think
about if you,
uh,
you know,
I was talking about jamie kilstein
earlier were accidental tweeted or
texted,
jamie used to be but social justice and
he was describing how he would go after
people and then he would be locked onto
his phone all day long,
look at the responses and completely
addicted to it no matter what he did
throughout his day.
He was checking his phone every couple
minutes and couldn't help that
compulsion.
That's a lot of people out there that
are locked into this.
Yes,
it is an addiction.
I've had to get.
I mean,
like I had a small period of a few
months where I had not really been on
twitter.
I joined the times.
That sort of thing happened to me and
then I was like,
this is horrible.
Like I hate the way this is physically
making me feel like I'm nauseous and
sweating like,
I,
I hate this,
I can't do this.
IT's to be a better way saying something
mean to you,
oh my god.
And then you look at it and you're like,
I should say something back like this
really intense.
And then people,
you see them like formulating and like,
hey man,
what are you doing?
I'm in,
I'm in the middle.
I'm in mortal kombat here.
Mortal online to know you,
you catch yourself.
Like I remember I was at a dinner party
once and I was like ta describing some
twitter fight I was at and I was like,
oh my god,
I've become one of those people and I'm,
I'm not going to allow myself to be thAt
person.
But you have to fight it.
You do have to fight it and you have to
be aware of what it is,
you know,
like it feels like something you have to
pay attention to.
Right.
But the beauty is that I get to write
for the New York times.
Yeah.
I'd like to put my energy into that.
And when you do get criticism from your
articles,
do you get it in the form of like,
what is really scary email today?
I get emails,
I get tweets,
I get everything,
everything everyone gets.
I get letters in the mail sometimes.
Do you want to talk about it?
Like what?
No,
I mean it's.
Wait.
No,
I mean I can.
I can.
I don't think it's so unusual,
like that's part of,
you know,
I write things that people find
provocative.
I expect to provoke a reaction.
I'm okay with that.
And when there are things that are
scary,
you know,
the New York times is really good about
monitoring that
there's no way I don't like to be in a
field that's got getting attacked as an
enemy of the people by the president of
the United States.
We're super excited about that.
It's so bizarre.
The guy,
he's so petty that he calls it like the
failing needed,
but it's so irresponsible like there.
I'm shocked that there has not been more
violence perpetrated on members of the
press.
I'm really,
I really am.
What do you think happens with him?
I don't know who can feed us.
I don't know who can beat him.
Who do you think can beat him?
That's good question.
Don't know.
Hillary can't.
I'm so worried.
She's going to run again.
She's going to muscle her way to the
top.
I don't know who can beat him right now
and I'm,
I'm,
I don't know.
Why do you think that the question
right?
If things keep going further and further
south.
What
about someone who is a centrist
democrat?
Doesn't that make more sense that
someone who's gonna who's a rational
person who's on the right is going to
look at this person who's maybe
economically conservative but socially
liberal and say this is really where I'm
leaning towards one on the far left and
like on,
on an identity politics platform scares
me.
Yeah.
That's not going to work well,
could it?
Because I don't know because trump's
whole thing was screw the center.
I Just need to make my base go ape shit
crazy for me,
but they're still apeshit crazy and no
matter what he does and I'm worried that
the left that the democrats are going to
try and replicate that strategy and be
like,
we just need to make our base go ape
shit crazy rather than running someone
that can win the center.
I see where You're going,
but I think that this is maybe my
liberal bias,
but I think that people on the left
wouldn't fall for that the same way
people in the right word.
I don't think people on the left who saw
someone who went ape shit full woke far
left.
I think there's a lot of people in the
center and be like,
well,
I'm going to just get a vote.
Libertarian man.
I'm going to vote for Gary Johnson or
some shit.
but okay,
so who's in right now?
So we have kamala,
kirsten gillibrand,
whole month's dress,
monster ds ideas.
Well,
when she was 22 she had.
She's in a solid toady.
What does that mean?
She is toady.
I think that I use that word correctly.
Jamie,
can you check with toady means like
towing the line?
Is that what it means?
No,
I think it's like a
t o a d I e.
What does that mean?
I think it means,
and I think it means
there you go.
Toady definition of tony's,
a person,
planners or defers to others.
Can I kind of self serving reasons a
sycophant.
So she's in assad,
sycophants that what you're saying?
Yeah,
that's true.
That's
known about her.
Like what did she say?
That I don't.
I don't remember the details I've read
it should say that before we say that
about or we should probably read it
rather well.
I have read it.
Normally we should write.
Oh,
okay.
Just so we know what she said.
Look,
I really enjoyed talking to her.
I like her a lot.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Like talking to her.
A lot of talking to her.
I don't know about.
I think she's like the mother lode of
bad ideas.
Whoa.
I'm pretty positive about that.
especially on the side,
but maybe I'm wrong.
I don't think I'm wrong.
Well,
my take on her was that I think as a
person who's coming from the left who is
also a veteran and is very articulate
and sensible and a woman,
and in talking to her and we didn't get
into a sod or any of those things,
but talking to her about what she feels
is wrong with the current administration
and the way things are running in a
direction she thinks things could go in,
sheds a very promising ideas.
I don't.
I didn't know about this,
doesn't she?
also.
Did she ever apologize for believing in
conversion therapy for?
I didn't even know she believed in
conversion therapy.
Am I crazy?
Is that real?
I'm almost positive.
This is real.
I think her father ran a center therapy.
You're talking about gay?
Yes.
No.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
I never heard that.
I did hear something about when she was
very young.
She was like 22.
She had said something about gay
marriage and civil unions.
If she apologized for it and said that
she evolved.
She reveals she met assad In Syria
without informing top democrats.
She's.
She said she went on a fact finding
mission in supportive piece for syrian
people,
but characterize us backed rebels' as
terrorists.
yeah.
She's.
I mean,
I can keep looking,
but I just.
I'm telling me it's time to research
everything all at the same time.
I can come back on When I do,
but let's,
let's.
We can do this another time,
but what,
who do you think stands out for you as
someone that would make a good
president?
She wants touted working for an anti gay
group that,
that conversion therapy.
Anyway,
she wants touted working for an anti.
She worked for an anti gay group.
She worked for them like she had a job
there,
you know,
I'm worried as a person who's been
called.
All right adjacent worry about labels.
No,
I understand,
but you know what I mean?
Rep tulsi gabbard in the early two
thousands touted working for her
father's anti gay organization which
mobilized to pass a measure against same
sex marriage in Hawaii and perverted and
promoted controversial conversion
therapy.
Yeah.
Fyi.
Conversion therapies.
The weirdest shit of all time.
There was a an article that I read
about,
they were.
They were manipulating pleasure.
It turned out it's.
I start,
I started reading it from a study on
rats.
They did this thing with rats where they
provided.
They've figured out a way to give rats
orgasms.
I figured out a way to jazz up the
pleasure center of the brain
and they would do anything to do it.
They would,
they would shock,
they would run up,
pass an area that shocked them,
like they do do anything to get to this
area where they could have these orgasms
and they would have them up to 2000
times a day.
They wOuld just not just all day long
and in reading male and female rats,
rats,
just just,
just,
just rats trying to come.
And so when I was a love that we're in
our three talking about rat orgasms.
Oh,
it's amazing studies.
Amazing.
Well tHis.
Sorry folks.
Mr. Mrs. Weiss time to turn away.
They did it with a gay man while they
were doing this.
This is in the 19 seventies.
There's a couple different studies that
they did,
but one of them they did with this gay
guy where they tried to stimulate
certain parts of his brain while they
were showing him heterosexual porn and
they were trying to convert him into
being heterosexual and apparently they
had some meager amount of success with
this where he engaged in sexual
relationships with women and and
apparently even enjoyed it and they did
something to the literally stimulate a
part of his brain that would excite
arousal and tried to connect that with
with heterosexual porn and made him
orgasm,
made him masturbate to orgasm while they
were doing this and showing him straight
porn and the idea was they were going to
reprogram his mind.
HOw'd that work out?
It didn't,
but It did.
It did in terms of short term,
but it didn't mean it must have been
just massively confused.
Obviously sexuality is not just about
what makes you have an orgasm.
No,
it's not.
It's also incredibly.
It's incredibly complex and one of the
things that happens is you get.
You can have gay experiences when you're
young.
If someone does something to you in
imprints upon you arousal at a young age
with,
with gay experiences,
sometimes even heterosexual men will get
aroused by certain gay images and gay
things because of their past because of
that,
like chris,
but
that we're all on a spectrum of
sexuality and
yes,
I think so for sure.
We all certainly are,
but it's also speculative.
How much of that spectrum is influenced
by your environment versus your jeans
and you know,
and this is very taboo for some people
discuss even though it's really
fascinating.
Human sexuality is incredibly
fascinating and there's,
there's some major taboo areas of
exploration and when you start looking
at like what makes a person gay or
straight,
whether it's nature or nurture,
whether it's a combination of those
things where if someone's just radically
gay from the room or whether someone's
radically straight from the womb,
these,
these studies where they were trying to,
they were trying to turn someone with
science and they were trying to turn
someone straight.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's very.
You couldn't do it today.
You'd never be able to do it today in
America.
Yeah,
I believe it was 71.
They did it.
I'll look it up.
I'll send it to you.
It's crazy.
Widely criticized,
but heavily studied.
The woman,
they did it to a woman to and they.
They stuck these.
This woman had a problem with pain
killers and so they figured out a way to
wire her brain.
Is this like electric shock therapy?
These fucking dental drills,
but only on their brains
can do whatever they wanted to get high.
WHen does this.
Now's the time we break out the elan
musk.
We'd.
OH my god.
That was crazy.
I watched every minute of it was stop
thing.
We drank whiskey for two hours for when
I say crazy,
I mean like an amazing get like
journalistically.
Yeah,
it was awesome.
No
is really cool and I have to thank some
of his friends that I'm friends with
that convinced him to do that.
Yeah,
that was a fascinating conversation.
I thought it was nothing.
I thought so.
We smoked a little pot.
I didn't.
I literally didn't think of it.
Amy thing he does.
It's fascinating.
That's what.
Why aren't really wanted to talk to him
about what his thought process like,
like what's going on.
I know something different is going on
in his head.
Right?
You know,
you ever talked to someone where you
know,
because I have children and I do like to
think of people's babies that become,
you know,
what they are,
see them in front of me right now and
this constant state of evolution.
But sometimes I'll run into someone
that's depressingly stupid where I
realized like,
god damn,
this guy's got a nine volt brain.
They just do.
Some people just do it.
No one wants to admit that.
And we're not talking about mental
retardation or any sort of a disease
down syndrome or something like that.
We're talking about people that are just
toxic,
stupid and they do exist.
Just like some people have big noses,
some people have little noses.
So when you were talking to elon musk,
did you get the sense that you were
talking to like a genius?
What did it feel like?
I'm a chimp champion here.
That firstly.
Yeah.
I'm not exactly what was going to say I
am that toxically stupid person talking
to this guy really wants to create
gigantic power stations in Australia to
fix their grid and wants to shoot
fucking rockets into space and they
literally let them drill under la.
They're like,
go ahead.
What are you going to do?
We're going to drill holes.
God,
people are completely fascinated by him
and they would have watched you.
They would have watched like a silent
movie with you and him for two hours and
millions of people would have watched
that.
I don't know about that.
No,
I didn't want to hear him talk for sure,
but I'm saying like anything he does,
it's completely fascinating to people.
Well,
he's
gitelman super genius.
Legitimate,
like when he's not full of shit is that.
That is his thought process is
extraordinary,
but one of the things that was really
clear from talking to him was that it's
uncomfortable that his whole life it's
been this tornado of ideas is going
against his head and he's like,
you wouldn't want to be me.
She's like,
what do you mean man?
You know,
he's like,
it never shuts off,
you know,
like,
oh,
But he wasn't,
he wasn't,
woe Is me.
He was being factual and he was
probably,
it's probably like,
you know,
some people have a ringing in their
ears.
They have tinnitus,
rock concerts,
too many.
I think he's got a ringing of ideas.
So while you and I are having this
conversation,
I don't have a fucking
anything else going on in my head.
There's nothing,
there's nothing else back there.
It's just you and I talking and there's
no fucking grand plans.
I think he's like remapping civilization
and trying to make a better yacht.
I'm thinking I want a burger.
That's what I'm thinking.
He's,
he's just,
you know,
just like shaquille o'neal is eight feet
tall and some people are four feet tall.
You know,
some people just have a brain.
I mean there's no,
there's no level playing field.
It comes to
anything politik performance or,
or mental performance.
Parents are,
like you were talking about before,
like I won the lottery when it comes to
that.
I'm so aware of that and everything in
my life that made everything possible.
Well,
that is the real,
the only saving grace of the concept of
white privilege is that we do have to
recognize that some people got a really
good deal and some people got a really
terrible deal,
but the only reason why white privileges
even something to consider Is that
racism is real.
That white privilege is not if the world
was barry weiss or kinds of privilege.
Right?
But what I was going to say is if the
world was people like you or people like
jamie,
we would never have to worry about
racism because it wouldn't even be a
consideration.
Jamie's on black twitter every day.
Love jamie.
What are you doing over there?
it's just been a producer working.
Um,
but you know what I'm saying?
like if,
if it was no racism,
that concept would be totally
irrelevant.
And what we would be concentrating on
is,
you know,
who's making the best buildings?
Who's making the best music?
What,
what,
what were the contributions to culture
we wouldn't care about if they were
coming from asian people or west indian
people,
we wouldn't care,
but I think the contribution of the left
to make people recognize
dunno,
privilege of all kinds,
that's useful.
It's actually useful to think about
that.
What is not useful is to say because you
were x,
y,
or z thing,
therefore you're out.
Yes.
Therefore you have no stake and
therefore in fact you have sort of less
of a claim on truth and morality.
I'm sure you're aware of what happened
recently with the woman from cnn who was
on patriot
radio.
She was amazing.
She accused an african american
gentleman who she didn't do her
research.
She instead of arguing the idea or
discussing these ideas and she said,
because of your white privilege,
it's blinding you.
And he was like,
he,
he gave her rope to,
you know,
to me like as a person does jujitsu.
He lIke gave her a room.
He gave her room and she went right into
the choke.
she has sank the choke in herself.
She explained it even further and he
said,
I hate to break it to you,
but I'm black and she must have just
felt her whole life.
All of our Intellectual credibility just
go fucking blush flushed down the toilet
like,
oh my god,
you just got exposed and this is what
people love about preposterous thinking.
It's preposterous thinking.
If it's given enough time,
it's eventually gonna slam into a wall
and that's what we saw.
We saw a truck with a fucking brick on
the accelerator,
just slammed right into the wall because
she thought she had a path that you
couldn't stop and this is the path.
It's like if you're playing chess,
but you have one super powerful move
that it works.
It's not like a rook or a queen.
No,
it has no rules.
It just king.
I just.
That's what she did.
Basically.
She had this super
powerful thing and it didn't work and it
didn't work because this guy was a part
of the protected class that she was part
of and she tried her thinking of just
like shortcuts to dismissing people,
but no one else could pull that off
except a black man or black woman if,
if,
because of who he is.
He had the checkmate and he's like,
ha ha,
and the whole world went,
because we've all seen that,
but it you can't say anything.
If I.
If I was having this discussion with her
and she said,
because of your white privilege,
I'd have to say,
look,
okay,
let's go through the thing.
Let's unpack that.
A fucking hate that word unpack.
I hate it because it's always brought.
It's always brought out by people who
really aren't on packing shit.
They're just explaining to you how their
ideology trumps your ideology and it's
almost always like this preposterous way
of describing things.
Let me unpack that for you.
Oh fuck you.
But
he didn't have to.
He didn't have to say that.
He said,
I'm black,
and that was the ultimate unpacking.
Boom,
and whether he's right or she's right.
It's like the those words white
privileged.
Oh,
that's.
That creates so many fucking headaches.
It does,
but you think it's real though?
Yes,
for sure.
It's real.
It's real because it's racist.
Don't target me the way they would
target a black person that's 100 percent
real.
It gets used in this sloppy way and it
gets used to dismiss people and I don't
think that's useful in the real problem
is not white privilege.
The real problem is racist.
Actual racists.
That's the real problem and if there was
no racist,
that white privilege wouldn't be a
thing.
It's only a thing because of racists and
it's only a thing with racists without
racist.
It doesn't exist.
The problem with african americans or
asians or asians as the real,
like this is a weird one,
right?
Like the harvard thing where asians are
denied entry into harvard with the same
standards that white people have,
like if because of racism,
because they're good because they study
so hard and they do too,
but if you look at that law suit in the
language that the school use to sort of
describe them as antisocial and robotic
and all of these stereotypes.
So awful.
It's crazy.
It's so crazy.
You should read wesley yang on this.
He's a really interesting writer about
this.
We're saying you should have in mind,
I would love to book a book of essays
called.
I think it's actually called the souls
of yellow folk this year.
I used to.
I used to teach taekwondo for a living
and it was around a lot of korean people
and uh,
one when I learned taekwondo from a
korean man,
when I learned and I was around so many
korean people,
I was stunned by the,
the work ethic that exists in these,
these families and the,
the humbleness and the,
the,
the way it was almost expected
that you never brag and that you work
harder than anybody.
And I had a friend who was,
he was on the u,
s taekwondo team to compete in the
olympic games.
He was working on his school work.
He was going through his residency,
so he's probably working on schoolwork
10 to 12 hours a day in between classes.
He would put his book bag on.
He would fill his book bag up with with
books and run the stairs at the
university up and down.
And then he would come to the gym at
night and train and then he would travel
to compete with the world team and all
the.
All the.
Meanwhile he was in his college.
He was,
he was going to medical school.
I mean he had bags under his eyes.
You could stuff christmas trees.
It was fucking insane.
This guy was always tired,
but the work ethic that he had was just.
I didn't have one 10th of that worth
work ethic.
It was.
It was impossible to ignore and he was
so spread then and so tired all the
time.
But he kept working and he would talk
about his culture and he would talk
about his family and what is expected of
him.
Like he's like,
man in my house like that.
You just fucking did it.
Like you don't.
You're just not.
There's not like,
oh,
I feel tired today.
Fuck you.
Get up,
go to work.
And that attitude has allowed so many
asian people that discipline and,
and,
and just this culture of performance and
of achievement where it's so,
it's so cherished that is allowed so
many asian people to excel in,
in academia.
And the fact that harvard somehow or
another steps in and says,
warm,
we're gonna.
We're gonna.
Make it more difficult for you because
you work so hard.
that is so crazy and so weird.
It's so weird that they as this.
I mean,
if you think about,
if you think about institutions of
higher learning,
harvard is the first one you think about
this number one,
it's number one,
I call he graduated from harvard.
Oh whoa,
dun dun,
right?
Harvard.
And to,
to have them so blinded,
it's,
it's amazing that they will be racist
against the best performance because
they're performing too well and there's
a disproportionate number of them in the
university.
So we're gonna make it harder.
We're going to raise your standards.
Yeah.
I just think that the actual,
like the stereotypes and the way that
they sort of fucking crazy.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
You had them on.
I would love to.
Where's he out of?
Do you know?
Montreal?
Montreal.
Okay.
I've actually never.
I'm trying to think if I've ever met
him.
I've never met him,
but he's,
he's an interesting writer and he'd be
really,
really good on this.
Better than me.
Especially because I'm fading.
Well,
let's wrap it up.
We're,
we're three hours and 20 minutes.
are you serious?
There's a time warp in this
light in here.
Oh,
there's 3:25.
Well,
there's.
Look,
I'm so happy we finally got together and
talked.
It was wonderful to have this
conversation with you.
I really appreciate it.
I was very impressed by you and thank
you very much.
We're going to trip.
We're going to go to on trip.
We're going to do it.
Jamie's coming.
It's gonna.
Bring this camera.
Thanks so much.
Thanks everybody.